So I'm going to launch right into it.
I like this story as well.
This is the story of Noah and the flood
and then the tower of Babel,
which I think are juxtaposed very
interestingly.
The Tower of Babel is one of those
stories like cain enabled.
It's only a few lines long.
It's like a fragment in some sense,
although the story of noise quite a well
developed narrative,
um,
but like the other stories that we've
covered,
it is relevant at multiple levels of
analysis simultaneously.
And so what I'm going to do to begin
with is to start with some background
information,
so some psychological background
information so that the story makes
sense.
And the first thing that I'd like to,
I'd like to make a case for is that the
you bringing to bear on the world and a
priority of perceptual structure.
And that's really an embodied structure
and it's a consequence of the three and
a half billion years that you've spent
putting your body together,
which is a tremendous amount of time and
not only your body but your mind of
course,
because your mind is part of your body.
And very much embedded within it,
you know,
you,
you tend to think that you have your
brain in your head and it's sort of
floating separate from the rest of your
body,
but it's not really true.
You're tremendous massive system of
neurons running through your entire
body,
autonomic neurons in the autonomic
nervous system than there are on the
central nervous system.
So that's a lot of neurons.
And then your central nervous system,
of course,
enables you to exercise voluntary
control over your musculature and also
to receive information from it.
Your brain is really distributed through
your body.
One of the things you may not know is
that people who are paraplegic can walk.
If you,
if you suspend them above a treadmill,
their legs will walk by themselves with
no voluntary control.
So your spine is capable of quite
complex activity.
In fact,
when you walk,
mostly it's a controlled fall and mostly
your spine is doing it.
And so.
So anyways,
the point of all that is that you don't
have a blank slate consciousness that's
interpreting a world that manifests
itself as segregated objects in some
straight forward.
Since you have a built in interpretive
system that's extraordinarily deeply
embedded and invisible because you might
think about it as the implicit structure
of your unconscious.
It's what it's what gives rise to your
conscious experience and and it presents
you with the world that that's one way
of thinking about attending a good way
of thinking about it,
the psychoanalytic way of thinking about
it as well as the neuroscientific way of
thinking
about it because one of the things
that's pretty interesting about modern
neuroscientists,
especially the top rate ones,
and those are usually the ones that are
working on emotions.
As far as I've been able to tell our are
often quite enamored of the
psychoanalyst Jaak.
Panksepp was a good example of that
because they came to understand that the
psychoanalysts insistence on underlying
unconscious personified motivations was
actually an accurate reflection of how
the brain worked.
And so to think of yourself as a loose
collection of autonomous spirits,
it's governed by some overarching
identity.
Is is is a reasonable way of thinking
about it.
The question is,
or a question that arises from that is
what is the nature of this a priority
structure that you use to interpret the
world and I think the clearest answer to
that is that it's a story.
Then you live inside the story and
that's very,
very interesting to me because I believe
I have a couple of videos that laid this
out.
I believe that Darwinian
presuppositions,
or at least as fundamental as Newtonian
presuppositions.
I actually think they're more
fundamental and that the fact that we've
evolved story like structures through
which to interpret the world indicates
to me that there's something deeply true
about story like structures where their
true,
at least in so far as the fact that
we've developed them means that here we
are living and that it's taken three and
a half billion years to develop them.
They're,
they're highly functional and so we
don't have much better definition of
truth and highly functional.
You know that that's about as good as it
gets.
Partly because we're limited creatures
and we don't have omniscience knowledge,
and so the best we can do with our
knowledge,
generally speaking,
is to note its functionality and improve
it.
When it fails to work properly.
I think the scientific method actually
does that and so the fact that we've
evolved a story like structure through
which to interpret the world.
That's pretty damn interesting.
It says something fundamental about
stories and it's.
It's strange in the same way that the
fact that we have hemispheric
specialization for the known and the
unknown or for chaos and order order and
chaos or respectively also says
something fundamental about the nature
of the world.
If you assume that you know,
we've evolved to reflect the structure
of the world broadly speaking,
and that's obviously not just the
physical structure,
the atoms and the molecules,
but all of the pattern manifestations of
the physical molecules as they build
structures of increasing complexity
across time.
That would include human interactions
and all of and political interactions,
economic act interactions,
familiar interactions.
All of those things that are a very
important part of our reality,
but perhaps in some sense not as
fundamental,
the physical attributes that the
physicists concentrate on.
So we live in stories and so I want to
talk to you a little bit about stories
and about their structure because when
you understand a little bit about the
structure of stories than a whole array
of things about mythology,
all of a sudden make overwhelming sense
and it's so useful because what you see
is that many of the things that are
standard occurrences in your life,
everyone's life that are portrayed
universally and mythology and it's very
helpful because first of all,
Dee Dee isolates you.
One of the things you learn as a
clinical psychologist contra the anti
psychiatry lists,
let's say,
is that diagnosis is often a relief to
people.
You know there's a problem with being
diagnosed because then you might be
labeled and then the label can follow
you for the rest of your life.
And once you're labeled as something,
then strange things happen around you
that is often reinforced that label.
Maybe you start acting it out more or
are you adopted as an identity,
but there's a flip side of that,
which is that the last thing that you
ever want to hear when you go see a
physician or psychologist is,
you know,
I've never seen a case like yours
before,
right?
That is not a relief man,
because if the message is I've never
heard anything like what you're telling
me,
the outcome is either going to be not so
good for you or you're not going to get
listened to it all,
right?
Because you're such an anomaly that
you're,
you're actually in your existence is
annoying to the integrated knowledge
structure of the medical professional
that you are attempting to receive
advice from.
Well,
it's definitely the case because they,
you know,
if you can be put in a box,
then the box tells the doctor what to do
with you and that's actually a relief to
the doctor,
but also a relief to you,
right?
Because you want to know.
So you come and you say,
look,
I can't go out of my house much anymore.
I'm afraid on elevators.
Um,
I have heart palpitations and I
sometimes they end up in the emergency
room.
Increasingly my interactions in the
world are restricted.
I find myself staying at home afraid I'm
going to die of a heart attack.
And the psychologist says,
well,
you have agora phobia,
and it's like lots of people have that
and here's usually how it develops and
here's the treatment course and you
know,
we can probably do something about that.
And it's like,
well,
you're not going to die of a heart
attack now probably that's a real
relief.
You're not crazy in a completely unique
way and you're crazy in a way that might
be treatable,
you know,
and it's.
So,
it's such a relief because people come
in there with a pile of snakes,
have indeterminant magnitude and they
walk out with one manageable snake and
it's still a snake.
But you know,
one manageable snake beats a hydra.
Right?
So,
all right,
so,
so back,
back to stories.
So
the stories that we tell and that we
live in are fundamentally ways that we
deal with the complexity of the world.
And the fundamental problem with the
world as far as I can tell,
is that not only is it complex beyond
your comprehension,
but the complexity shifts in
unpredictable ways.
So that's the Darwinian conundrum
actually that's wide darwinism seems to
be a practical necessity with regards to
the continuation of life because because
of the complexity changes unpredictably,
you can't necessarily tell what's going
to work in the future.
And so the Darwinian process solves that
by generating quasi random variations
and letting,
whichever one by happenstance happens to
work in that environment,
survive.
Now it's not random precisely because
the underlying structure is conserved.
It's very rare that a child would be
born with an extra arm or something like
that.
And like the skeletal structure that you
inhabit is shared by animals going way,
way back.
In evolutionary history,
there's a lot of conservation and in the
evolutionary process,
but so there's variation within
conservation,
like music.
It's a good,
it's a good way of thinking about it.
So
the,
the stories that we tell have exactly
the same structure.
They have this,
this core element with variations and
so,
alright,
I'll turn to the stories.
And so the first problem,
as I mentioned,
is a complexity problem.
Things are just too complicated to get a
handle on and that actually has serious
consequences because what happens to
everyone eventually is that their lives
become so complicated that they die.
So and that and that and many terrible
things can happen to you on the way to
dying as well that are complex
complexity related,
right?
You can develop a serious illness that
you can't get a handle on.
You can hit a,
uh,
what would you call an impasse in your
relationship that you cannot get past
and see?
No way out of that happens to people
quite frequently.
People who are suicidal,
for example,
they often feel like they've been backed
into a corner that know that they have
no options.
They have no good options,
no matter which way they turn.
There's something terrible to face and
they can't see any way out of it.
And sometimes that's more true than
you'd like to think because we also tend
to like to think that people's problems
are primarily psychological,
but they're not that.
That's one thing you learned quite
rapidly as a clinician is that most of
the time people don't come to you
because they have mental illness.
They come to you because they have a
complexity management problem.
Their lives have got out of hand on them
and they don't know how to get them back
under control,
and so all sorts of things can do that.
And then of course that can make you
anxious or depressed to can trigger all
sorts of illnesses,
but the fundamental problem is still
that things have got beyond you and that
actually has a psychophysiological cost
that isn't merely psychological.
You have a limited amount of capacity
from from,
from,
from a resource perspective,
to deal with the emergent complexity.
You just.
There's just not enough of you.
You just,
you'll,
you'll exhaust your psychophysiological
resources.
If you get into a situation that's too
complex,
well that's what this.
That's what the idea of chaos
represents.
It represents that underlying complexity
that can manifest itself at any time and
it can manifest itself.
For example,
if you're.
If you wake up in the morning and you
know you'll feel an ache of some sort
and perhaps it's nothing and you ignore
it,
but it gets worse and you ended up going
to the hospital and you find out perhaps
for example,
that you have pancreatic cancer and
you're going to live for six months and
that's the end of that,
and so it's,
it's,
it's at that moment that you break
through the thin ice that everyone walks
on and you see what's underneath and
what's underneath is the ineradicable
complexity of life and that's chaos and
that's now.
It's taken people a long,
long time to get a grip on this
conceptuals.
What would you call it?
Conceptual Schema.
And the and human beings have done it
mostly with image and story before
they've been able to do it in any
articulated manner.
And so there are a set of images that
represent this underlying chaos and one
of them is the dragon of chaos that,
that precisely that.
And that's the dragon that the hero goes
out to confront.
That's the symbol of the unknown.
It's the thing that lurks underneath.
It's the thing that also guards treasure
because in the unknown,
there's possibility also the water that
was there that we talked about in the
Mesopotamian creation myth,
the water that's there at the beginning,
um,
both assault and the fresh water is
often assemble of pre cosmogony chaos.
Often people have dreams.
For example,
some of you,
you've had this dream,
I suspect you'll dream that you're in a
house that you know,
well,
now all of a sudden you discover a new
room or a set of new rooms or maybe a
set of rooms in the basement,
and often the rooms are,
are,
are not well organized and they're full
of water.
Those are very common things.
And what that means is that you've
broken through the constraints of your
conscious self understanding to a new
domain of,
of possibility,
but a new domain that needs a tremendous
amount of work.
It says,
well,
here's a new part of you,
but it's not well developed.
There's,
there's,
it's flooded.
It's flooded with chaos.
Essentially,
and it's water,
I think partly because chaos is not only
what you fall into when you're not
expecting it,
but it's also the unknown that you
confront forthrightly and generate new
things out of and water is a symbol of
life,
especially in the desert and of course
water.
Life is dependent on water and so
water's a natural symbol to utilize when
you're talking about something that's
life giving,
but also potentially deadly because a
little bit of water,
well that's a drink,
but a lot of water.
That's a ship wreck.
Right?
And so and those are the.
Those are the extremes.
Now.
There are accounts that are sort of
subtexts in genesis and elsewhere in the
Old Testament of God conquering a great
monster,
Leviathan or or a a,
a moth that has these sort of serpent
tile elements and making the world as a
consequence of that conflict.
So there's this idea that the world
creating force,
which we've talked about as the logos,
is the thing that continually confronts
chaos and that one way of thinking about
chaos is as a predatory reptilian
monster and often one that lives in the
depths or perhaps underwater,
and part of that I think is because we
actually use our Predator detection
circuit to do this sort of pre cognitive
processing.
And so the notion fundamentally is
anything that threatens you
instantaneously is something that your
Predator detection circuit should be
working with.
It's fast,
it's fast,
it's low resolution,
it doesn't have a lot of ideas,
but it's really,
really fast.
And that also accounts for capability
and tendency to very rapidly treat.
People who are upset are conceptual
structures as enemies of the predatory
variety.
We can fall into that in no time flat
because it's.
It's the archetype.
Here's something comes along to knock
you for a loop.
It's a shark.
It's something that lurks under the
water.
It's something that'll pull you down.
It's an enemy and and you should get
prepared and that's a reasonable
defensive strategy even though it also
has its dangers.
And can sometimes be wrong.
So the landscape within which we have to
erect our stories is fundamentally one
of an overarching chaos and chaos that
exceeds our capacity to comprehend in,
in any sense,
individually,
familial,
socially,
economically.
We're always threatened by the collapse
of the structures that we inhabit
constantly.
We have to work well.
It's like you own a house,
you know,
how much time do you spend maintaining a
house?
Well,
a lot.
And why is that?
Is because the house falls apart because
you're stupid and the house falls apart.
Well because you do repair is wrong or
you ignore things.
Right?
And I'm saying this actually for
technical reasons,
the house falls apart because you're
incompetent,
but even if you're competent,
the house falls apart,
right?
It's just entropy.
And so things have a proclivity to fall
apart on their own.
So you just have to run like mad just to
keep them doing what they're supposed to
be doing.
And then of course that is complicated
by your own willful blindness and
inadequacy as a repair person and
refusal to attend and all those other
things.
So.
So that's a very classic idea which
we'll return to.
One of the ideas that that Mircea
Eliana,
a famous historian of religions,
extracted from a very large corpus of
flood myths,
was the idea that the earth is
periodically flooded for two reasons.
One is things fall apart,
just entropy,
straight entropy.
It's,
I don't remember which law of
thermodynamics that is,
but it's one of the big laws of
thermodynamics.
So it's since it's one of the top three
and things fall apart of their own
accord and that's one of the things that
we have to contend with.
And then the rate at which things fall
apart is sped by the sins of men.
That's the other idea.
And you know that everyone knows that
because you know,
you know your car breaks down in the
highway and you think,
God,
that's so inconvenient.
And then you,
you know,
you shake your fist at the sky and then
there's part of you in the back of your
mind that goes,
God,
you know,
I knew that rattled that I wasn't paying
attention to actually signified
something.
You know,
and I,
I knew I should have paid attention to
it and I didn't,
and now I'm in the situation that I'm in
now and you know,
I know I bet you this happens to people
two or three times a week,
is they do something stupid that they
know they shouldn't have done,
that they told themselves not to do mere
seconds before and they know the voice
says,
don't do that.
Yeah,
yeah,
you do it.
You can get nailed for it exactly the
way that you knew you would get nailed
for it and then you're hurt doubly
because not only did it fall apart,
but you're the idiot that made it fall
apart,
knowing full well that was going to fall
apart and ignoring it.
And so that's the idea behind the notion
that there are two reasons that things
fall apart.
Thermodynamic entropy and the proclivity
of people not to attend to things they
know they should attend to and partly we
do that because if,
if a problem emerges,
it always announces itself.
Unless it's a really,
really tiny problem and you're
approaching it voluntarily,
voluntarily,
it always announces itself with negative
emotion and that's part of the Predator
detection circuited.
It announces itself in frustration or
disappointment or emotional pain or
grief or the paramount one,
anxiety and and no wonder because it's a
problem,
right?
And the logical one of the logical
responses is to sort of freeze in the
face of the problem,
but of course if it's a problem that has
to be addressed and solved,
freezing it and turning away from it is
not a good solution because since things
tend to fall apart on their own accord,
if you just leave the thing alone,
that's problem Madec.
It's just going to get worse,
not better.
Which is one of the things that's very
annoying about life.
So for example,
you know,
if you get a warning message from the
Tax Department,
the probability that ignoring that will
make it go away is zero,
right?
What'll happen instead is that the more
you ignore it,
the larger it will grow.
And if you ignore it long enough,
then it will turn into something large
enough to eat.
You and that will be the end of you.
I read in Harper's magazine at one point
that people would rather be mugged than
audited,
and so I believe that because the
mugging man that's over a couple of
minutes of sheer terror,
lost your wallet,
the way you walk the audit,
that's like,
that's like a semi fatal disease.
So that's chaos now.
It's the idea here too is that that's
the chaos.
That's the psychological ideas that
that's also the chaos that whatever is
being represented in genesis as the
spirit of God extracts order out of at
the beginning of time and it's also that
which we're constantly contending with
as we struggle in the same manner to
construct and maintain habitable world.
So it's brilliant.
It's brilliant.
You know,
when I first put together the
relationship between what Iliana called
the pre cosmogony chaos and the Predator
predatory landscape that surrounded our
ancestors and the manner in which we're
structured neurologically to respond to
all of that.
I thought it was.
It was like an an amazing epiphany
because it's self evidently the case
that the world is too complicated for us
to deal with and that's one of the
problems that we face on an ongoing
basis and then the question is,
well,
what do you do about that?
And if you ignore it,
it gets worse,
so ignoring it doesn't work and so we
know what doesn't work and so if
ignoring it doesn't work,
then attending to it might work and then
I found out with the Egyptians,
for example,
that horace was the god of attention.
In the same thing happened among the
Mesopotamians with Marduk and his ring
of eyes.
It's like what's the way to forestall
the catastrophe of things falling apart
in the answer that is by attending to
the voluntarily attending to them and
that slot very nicely into the hero
mythology that promotes the idea that if
there's a dragon in the whereabouts in,
in the near,
in the,
in the neighborhood.
Let's say that hiding in the basement
just makes it grow larger.
It's time to go out and confront the
damn thing and the general stories are
as well.
You might get killed because it's a
dragon,
but it's only might as opposed to
definitely will get killed if it happens
to attack you at three in the morning at
home when you're hung over and it's been
a bad day and you don't have your,
you know,
are your sword and your shield at the
ready,
which is generally what happens to
people who avoid things,
so it's not something that should be
recommended.
You're screwed both ways.
That's one of the things that's so nice
about being deeply pessimistic.
It's so freeing because one of the
things,
well,
it's very frequent.
It's such a relief and it is really a
useful habit to develop is sometimes no
matter what you do,
you're in trouble and that's a relief
because then you can stop scrabbling
around for the way out.
There's no way out man.
It's like you can pick murder,
wretched death,
a or slightly less wretched death be
something like that,
but.
And I know that's a terrible way of
looking at things,
but it is extraordinarily useful to
understand that many times you get your
choice boils down to picking the least
bad option and if that's all you can do,
if that's how life is revealing itself
to you,
it's like,
well,
more power to you,
the least bad option.
That's the best you can do.
And and it's good enough,
especially compared to the alternative
which is the most bad option.
So all right now.
So the fundamental reality of things is
complexity beyond comprehension.
And then the question is,
well,
how is it that you manage that?
And partly you manage that and this is
where the PA,
the image of the patriarchal order comes
in in the positive manner.
I might point out because in the absence
of patriarchal structure,
for lack of a better lexicon,
there's nothing but chaos and I wouldn't
recommend chaos because it's it.
There's a lot of it and there isn't that
much of you.
And if you think you can handle it
without an a priori structure and
without a sociological structures
surrounding you,
then you don't know anything at all
about human beings.
Because one of the things I've noticed
for example,
is that it's,
it's unbelievable the degree to which
our sanity depends on our functioning,
sociological structure.
And here's why.
Well,
first of all,
you kind of need to know what to do
every day.
You have to have a routine because
you're an animal,
you know,
and you know if you have a dog or a cat,
dogs are really good example of this.
Dogs like routine,
they like to be walked the number of
times a day that they're supposed to be
walked and they get quite sick very
rapidly.
If you don't,
if you don't routinize their days,
children are exactly the same way.
Now you can overdo it,
right?
But still,
you know,
you need to know proximately when you
should get up to be approximately the
same everyday.
You need to know approximately.
You're going,
when you're going to eat,
you need to know what you're going to
eat.
You need to know who you're going to eat
with,
you need to know where to buy your food.
It's like 80 percent of your life,
70 percent of your life.
Something like that consists of those
things that you do every single day that
you repeat,
and those are often the things that
people think about as the trivial
elements of their life,
but one of the things I would like to
point out to you if you do the
mathematics I,
I did this with a client of mine who was
having a hard time putting his child to
bet they were having a fight every night
and I knew by that time the studies
indicate that most parents only spend 20
minutes per day of one on one time with
their child.
Now the reason for that is that people
are busy.
It's actually not that easy to Parse out
20 minutes of one on one time.
It's a lot bloody more time than you
think,
but that's all.
There is.
Twenty minutes he's spending like 40
minutes a day fighting with this kid,
trying to get the kid to go to bed and
that's not very entertaining,
you know,
you think,
well it's just having a scrap with a kid
about going to bed,
but it's.
No,
no,
no.
If it happens every day,
it's a catastrophe.
So you do the math,
so it will say five hours a week for the
sake of argument,
just to keep it simple.
It's 20 hours a month.
It's 240 hours a year.
That 60 slash 40 hour work weeks.
So that guy was basically spending a
month and a half of work weeks doing
absolutely nothing but having a wretched
time fighting with his son,
trying to get them to go to bed.
Horrible.
Right.
That's just way too much time to spend
doing something like that.
If you want to actually have a positive
relationship with someone because it's
just too.
It's just too punishing him so well.
So you need structure,
you need predictability and you need
more of it than you think.
Just to keep you sane.
Now,
if you're lucky and maybe a bit odd,
you can deviate five percent from the
norm or 10 percent from the norm or
something like that carefully and
cautiously,
as long as the rest of you is all well
ordered in informative manner,
you might be able to get away with that
and you might be able to sustain that
across time and people might be able to
tolerate you if you do it or maybe
you'll get really lucky and you happen
to be creative but reasonably well put
together and people will actually be
happy that there's something
idiosyncratic and unique about you.
But even under those circumstances,
mostly what you want is to have a
routine.
It's disciplined.
It's predictable and bloody well stick
to it.
You're going to be way healthier and
happier and Saner if you do that.
And then the other thing that you need,
because this is one of the things the
psychoanalysts got wrong,
I think is that they overestimated the
degree to which sanity was a consequence
of internal,
of being properly structured internally.
You know,
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view,
you're sort of an ego and that ego is
inside you and of course it rests on an
unconscious structure,
but the purpose of psychoanalytic
analysis is to sort out that unconscious
structure and the ego on top of it and
to make you a fully functioning and
autonomous individual,
but there's a problem with that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and antonymous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important.
The reason that you're saying,
if you're aware,
if you have a well organized unconscious
and ego is because other people can
tolerate having you around for
reasonably extensive periods of time and
we'll cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue,
and so what people are doing to each
other all the time,
just nonstop is broadcasting.
Sanity signals back and forth,
right?
It's like you smile at people if they're
well,
if they're not,
not only behaving property,
but behaving in a way that you would
like to see them continue to behave,
you frown at them.
If they're not,
you ignore them.
you shun them.
You,
you roll your eyes out them you manifest
to discuss face.
You don't listen to them.
You interrupt them.
You won't cooperate with them.
You won't compete with them.
It's like you're blasting signals and
other people about how to regulate their
behavior so frequently.
Well,
it just makes up all of your social
interaction and that's why we face each
other and we have emotional displays on
her face and we're looking at each
other's eyes and we know exactly.
We know as much as we can about what's
going on with each other given that we
don't have immediate access to the
contents of their consciousness,
and so partly what you're doing with
your routine is establishing yourself as
a credible,
reliable,
trustworthy,
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape.
Making sure that that's exactly what you
are and that's how you stay sane and so
what happens to people too,
if they don't have a routine and they
get isolated as they start to drift and
they drift badly because the world is
too complicated for you to keep it
organized all by yourself,
you just cannot do it.
So a lot of our.
So we outsource the problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
outsourced the problem of sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem
and so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have a
very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem all the
time.
It's like a stock market for sanity and
it's partly I,
I use that.
I use that definition with purpose
because the stock market does the same
kind of impossible thing,
right?
Because it tries to price things which
is impossible.
There is to how many things are there,
like a billion.
How in the world do you decide what the
price is?
You can decide what the price is.
That's why you have a stock market as
well.
In a free market,
I mean for,
for consumer goods is everyone's voting
on what the price of everything is all
the time and that's the way we figure it
out because it's actually.
It's technically impossible.
That's partly why the stock market
explodes now and then and there's
bubbles and all that sort of thing.
But anyways,
the point is things are chaotic.
In Alice in Wonderland,
when Alice goes down the rabbit hole,
that's the underworld,
right?
So now she's gone into the substructure
of being and she meets the Red Queen.
The Red Queen is Mother Nature and
mother nature is running around yelling
off with their heads off with their
heads,
which is of course what Mother Nature
Does and she tells Ellis in my kingdom,
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place.
And that's exactly right,
and that's a description of it.
In fact,
evolutionary biologists,
psychologists have picked up on that
phrase,
they call it the red queen problem,
and the Red Queen problem is
everything's after you all the time and
you're not smart enough to do anything
about it or enough about it,
and so that's a permanent existential
problem.
So how do you deal with that?
He's got a biological structure,
so your embodiment is part of the
solution to the problem and then you're
enculturated and because you're
enculturated,
we're taught a lot of things that you
need to know,
but mostly what you're taught is how to
communicate with other people in an
acceptable manner.
And then once you can communicate with
people in an acceptable manner,
then you can outsource your problems
constantly.
But you're doing constantly.
And so we're in this continual dynamic
exchange of problem solving.
So if you're a socialized person,
that's what you get access to.
And that's something to know if you're
going to have kids,
and I mentioned this,
I think in a previous lecture,
the per.
The purpose of being a parent for very
young children is to make your children
exceptionally socially desirable.
By the age of four,
because if you can do that,
there are set because everyone wants
them around and as soon as everybody
wants them around,
they want to play with them,
they want to cooperate when they want to
compete with them.
It's like the door is open,
the doors open and they stay sane
because they've got all sorts of people
who actually like them that are helping
them out.
And so that's your goal is to make them
as socially acceptable as you possibly
can,
have socially desirable as you possibly
can.
And that doesn't mean you render them
obedient without spirit.
Right?
That's,
that's a tyrants motive of enforcing
social acceptability is like never do
anything wrong.
Well that's not any way to.
I mean that's a good piece of advice,
you know,
like,
but it's missing the other half which is
do a bunch of things that are right.
So that,
so that people are thrilled to have you
around and do and encourage that.
That's what you want to do as a parent
as well as inculcating the order.
And so,
you know,
and in this little diagram I indicated
that there is God the father with his
son behind him and he's ruling over this
walled city,
so he's like the met has spirit of the
walled city.
It's very,
very nice,
very nice image,
brilliant image.
So it's the collective spirit of the
city.
That's another way of thinking about it
or the collective spirit of the city
across time or the collective spirit of
the force that built and maintained the
city across time even better and that's
associated with the sun because it's,
uh,
it's,
it's associated with enlightenment and
illumination and all of those things
that we associate with higher
consciousness and vision.
So brilliant image.
And then I overlaid this,
you know,
now of course the patriarchal aspect of
existence can become tyrannical.
Does that have quite regularly.
It's one of the existential dangers of
human civilization is that civilization
is a medication for chaos,
but it can spin out of control in and of
itself and become its own sort of
problem,
which is like a hyper order problem
generally,
which then produces a chaos problem.
So every solution carries within it
certain problems,
right?
Because no solution is perfect and so
you have to keep things in balance,
but it's one of the reasons that I'm
really a,
let's call it irritated about the
postmodernists because they keep
yammering about the patriarchy and it's
very,
very annoying because because it's self
evident that social structures are
tyrannical.
It's like that's not news folks,
that's obvious,
but that's not all they are and it's.
It's the.
It's the reduction of the entire complex
solution,
let's say to a unit dimensional problem.
It's just tight tyranny.
It's like,
no,
actually it's not just tyranny.
If you spend six months somewhere that
was just tyranny,
you'd know the difference very,
very rapidly,
and that doesn't mean that everyone
doesn't give up a pound or two or 10 or
20 of flesh to participate.
Even in a society that's as free as a
Western society is,
we all get crushed and molded by the
tyrannical force of social convention,
but at least in principle,
the benefit is worth the cost and then
it's also up to you to make sure that
you don't sacrifice more to the group
than you should and you can start to
tell if you're sacrificing more to the
group than you should because you start
to become resentful of other people.
That's part of that.
That's part of this psychological
mechanism that's informing you of that.
So it's up to you to fight against the,
you know,
the overarching pressure for conformity
to retain your individual logos,
let's say.
But that's sort of your problem.
It's like the group wants you to behave
now.
If you could behave and be creatively
productive,
so much the better,
but that's pretty damn rare.
So the group generally tends to settle
just for behave and there's a tyrannical
element of that.
But what the hell is the alternative?
It's,
you know,
our society is based on consensus and
the consensus is based on the sacrifice
of a certain sacrifice of individuality.
Even though individualities absolutely
necessary as a revitalizing force for
the society,
it's a very tight touched,
tough,
tough thing to manage property.
So anyways,
you have the your physiological
structure as your first line of ordering
in relationship to chaos because your
body presents you with the world in a
certain way.
And then the second line of defense is
something like this sociological
structure that you inhabit and we could
call those the competency hierarchies or
something like that and thank God for
them because you know,
maybe you're going to be able to
specialize in one or two things in your
life or five things,
but there's 300 things you need to know
and if it's just you,
you know,
you'll be doing your genius level
mathematics while your bath tub is
leaking all over your,
over your bathroom floor.
And that's not so good.
So you can call a plumber and hooray for
that.
So,
you know,
we tend to cooperate to keep chaos under
control and we tend to cooperate to keep
order under control.
And that's the political dialogue,
right?
We maintain the culture to keep chaos
under control and we balanced the
culture owed properly to keep the
culture under control and that way we
get to live reasonably peacefully,
reasonably productively for a reasonable
amount of time,
and that's the best that we can do and
we should have some gratitude when
that's working because the default
condition of things is that not only do
they not work very well,
they work worse and worse over time all
by themselves,
so anytime anything is working,
you should just be amazed by it.
All right,
so what is the frame look like?
Well,
I think it looks something like this,
and this is as far as I can tell,
this is the bare bones.
This is the bare bones of a variety of
things.
It's a bare bone story.
It's a verbal and conceptual framework.
It's a bare bone dazzle to,
to speak in Heideggerian terms.
It's like it's the bare bones world that
you live in.
You're always in one of these worlds.
There's no getting out of them.
You can move from one to another,
but you're always in a world like this
and so this is the world that you're in.
You're somewhere because you have to be
somewhere.
Now you might not know where that is,
which means that the somewhere that you
are is chaotic,
in which case you need to go over your
past in great detail and figure out
where you are.
It's like you're lost right to your,
your last and the problem with being
last is when you're lost.
You don't know where to go and the
problem with not knowing where to go is
there's a million places that you could
go and a million places is too many
places for you to go without dying,
so being lost is not good,
so you need to know where you are.
One of the things that we built online,
my partners and I is this program called
past authoring that helps people lay out
the narrative of their past to identify,
to break their life down into six
stages,
epochs.
We called them and then to identify the
emotionally significant moments in each
park and to write them out.
What happened negatively,
what happened positively,
what the consequences were,
what you derive from it,
perhaps what you could have done
differently,
perhaps what you learned from it,
all of that so that you can narrow in
zero in on determining precisely where
it is that you are right now and people
are often loath to do that because they
actually don't want to know because
they'd rather be spread out in as sort
of half blind manner in the fog hoping
that the place that they're at is better
than it really is,
and deluding themselves by remaining
vague.
Then to figure out,
I'm right here right now with these
specific problems,
but it's actually better to do that
because if you have a set of specific
problems and you've really narrowed them
down and really specified them,
then you probably start fixing them and
you can start fixing them and Mike Micro
ways,
bit by bit,
but there's no way you can do that
without knowing where you are.
It's impossible and you can kind of tell
if you don't know where you are.
It's quite straightforward.
If you are haunted by reveries of the
past for events that are older than
approximately 18 months,
if they continue to come up in your mind
over and over and your dreams over and
over,
you haven't extracted the world out from
your past experiences.
That potential is still trapped in the
past and to confront the potential means
to confront the dragon of the past,
and of course that's terrifying and
seriously be terrifying.
So for example,
maybe you're vague and ill formed and
ill defined because you were abused very
badly when you were a child,
four years old,
something like that,
and maybe you were abused by a family
member because that's generally who does
the abusing,
and so that just makes it worse.
And then what that means is that you've
got a implicit.
You've had an implicit encounter with
malevolent evil that no,
you've had to direct encounter with
malevolent evil,
but you have an implicit hypothesis of
malevolent evil that's plaguing you.
It's still there.
It's trapped in the memories,
right?
It's,
it's trapped in the representational
structure and as an adult you're now
faced with the necessity of articulating
that fully before you have any chance
whatsoever of freeing yourself from it,
and so that's no joke.
Lots of times people have to go into the
past.
That's what the psychoanalysts do and
say,
look,
here's something came along and just
bloody well knocked me over and it isn't
even that I repressed it,
which,
which I think was,
well,
we won't talk about Freud's errors
because freud was a genius,
so we'll just leave him alone,
but,
but sometimes it's not repression.
It's just the terrible things happen to
people at such a young age that there
isn't a bloody chance in hell of that.
They can figure out why they happened or
what to do with them or what they mean,
and then you can carry that with you and
you carry it with you.
It's like fear your,
your body encounters the world in stages
and it happens very rapidly.
Well,
it can extend over years,
but the initial stages happen very
rapidly.
So for example,
if you're walking down the road and you
hear a large noise,
a loud noise behind you,
he'll go like this.
That's a Predator defense response by
the way you crouched down and that's to
stop something from jumping on your back
and getting at your neck too easily.
That's like few million,
a few hundred milliseconds.
It's really faster,
even faster than that.
And it better be because something like
a snake,
but we'll say,
can nail you just right now so you
better be fast.
But it's low resolution.
It's like dangerous snake,
something like that or danger,
predatory cap.
It's that faxed and then you can unravel
that and categorize it.
But that takes time.
You do that with emotion and then you do
it with cognition.
And you can do that with longterm
thinking,
you know,
because maybe you've encountered someone
specifically malevolent and predatory at
work and it happens to people a lot
who's operating as a,
as a destructive bully and who seems to
have no positive function whatsoever.
And his only living that out.
And then you know,
you don't know what to do about it.
So you're,
you're in prey mode.
I don't mean this kind of mode,
although that would help too,
but I mean you're acting like a prey
animal and then you have this terribly
complex thing to decompose,
which is what the hell is up with this
person?
Why are they making my life miserable?
What is it about B that allows them to
make my life miserable?
That's a nasty little road to walk down
and you're stuck with having to.
You're stuck with having to decompose
it.
Maybe you can't.
Maybe formulating and explicit
philosophy of good and evil to deal with
something malevolent in your environment
actually just happens to be beyond you.
And that could easily be.
It's certainly the case for people who
are young and it's the case for plenty
of adults as well.
It's no simple thing to matt to manage.
It's something too that often soldiers
who have posttraumatic stress disorder
have to do because they've encountered
terrible things.
They've either done them or ran into
them and they need to update their moral
model of the world or if they end up in
something close to closely approximating
hell anyway.
So you need to know where you are.
That's this.
What is,
where are you?
So you're navigating your navigator.
You're a sailor on an ocean,
man.
That's what.
That's what you are.
You're a mobile creature.
You're going from point a to point b all
the time.
You're not sitting there glued to a rock
like some brainless,
you know,
sea creature.
There's a funny little creature called a
hydra.
Very simple little creature in his
juvenile stage.
It has a brain because it swims around.
But then when it turns into an adult,
it latches itself to Iraq and promptly
digests it's brain.
Because if you're just sitting on a rock
and you're not moving,
you don't need a brain.
So.
But that's not our issue,
right?
We're,
we're zipping around in the world and so
we're navigating agents.
And so to navigate,
there's two things you need to know.
And the first is,
where the hell are you?
Exactly,
precisely right.
Razor sharp.
What's good about you and what's bad
about you?
By your own,
by your own reckoning.
You don't have to.
You can ask other people,
but this is a game you play yourself.
It's like as far as I'm concerned,
I'm taking star,
what is it that's okay about being what
needs some work and you've got to watch
to not be too self critical when you're
doing that too because that can just be
another kind of flaw and then the next
is,
okay,
well where are you going?
What's your destination?
Well,
and that's what the frame is.
Now you know you could do that in a very
sophisticated way and you do that by
thinking consciously about who it is
that you are in an articulated manner
and where you want to go and why and how
you're going to get there and people
hardly ever do that.
That is,
that's come as such an absolute shock to
me as an educator.
I just because one of the other programs
I use this in my classes or what did the
other programs in this suite of programs
is called the future authoring program
and I started developing my maps of
meaning class,
which is where some of this materials
from andI got students to write about
their past.
It's like,
okay,
we're.
We're talking about stories,
so let's tell your story.
Who are you,
how'd you get here,
and what are you now that usually helps
people put things to rest.
Although it's quite stressful.
Well,
you're doing it.
Stress goes up when you're doing it and
maybe you feel miserable for a couple of
weeks and then stress goes down and it
stays down.
So that's.
And that's also why people don't do it
because who the hell wants to have their
stress go up?
But if it's temporary,
it's a sacrifice.
So then the next issue is,
well,
where are you going?
And one of the things that,
and this I just still,
I cannot understand you.
Students that had been in education
system for 15 years,
14 years,
high end students,
most of them not once in their whole
bloody life.
Did anyone ever get them to sit down for
like a day and say,
all right,
justify your existence.
Like seriously.
It's like here you are in university,
you're taking a bunch of courses,
you've got some sort of vague career
plan.
It's like defend the damn thing a bit
since you're going to go live it and
everything.
You're staking everything on it.
It's like,
what's your damn plan and why are you so
convinced that it's not the plan of a
babbling fool because if you haven't
thought about identity is and if you
really want to go out there and live
that out,
you know,
one of the things Carl Jung said was
that you were in a story whether you
know it or not,
and then he made two nice comments about
that.
If it's someone else's story,
you're probably going to get a bit part
and it might not be the one you want and
if it's a story that you don't know,
it might be one with a really bad ending
or maybe it's just bad period with a
worse ending.
And if you don't know what the story
that you're living out is,
maybe that's the one you know.
Maybe you got that from your mother.
You got it from your grandmother.
You got it from your aunt or God only
knows where you picked it up because you
pick up things like mad because that's
what human beings are like,
so maybe you're living a malevolent
tragedy unconsciously,
and then one thing you might ask
yourself is,
well,
how wretched and miserable is your life?
Let's add few title to that.
How wretched,
miserable and futile is your life?
And you might say,
well yeah,
70 percent on each count.
It's like,
then you're probably unconsciously
living out a malevolent tragedy and
maybe that's not for the best.
Oh,
it's either that or the whole universe
hates you,
right?
Or 70 percent hates you,
you know,
so.
So anyways,
you know,
we got students to start writing in
detail about not what they wanted.
It's not a career thing because that's
the closest people usually get is they
have a career plan.
It's like,
no,
it's not a career plan.
That's,
that's peripheral important.
But peripheral,
it's like,
all right,
you got three years,
man,
you're going to live them anyways.
Devote those three years to setting the
world around you so that it's the best
it can possibly for you as if you were
taking care of yourself as if you cared
for yourself.
Well.
What would that look like?
You know,
let's say just for the sake of argument,
if you figured out where you were that
you could have,
what would be best for you?
Well,
what is that?
I bet you never asked.
People don't ask and so life comes out
them like random snakes and they sort of
fend them off and life goes by and
things don't work out the way people
expected them to,
but a huge part of that is they didn't
know where they were because they
wouldn't look or didn't know that they
should look.
Ignorance,
willful blindness,
right to great catastrophes,
and they never figured out where they
wanted to go or why.
Now there's a problem with figuring out
where you want to go and the problem is
is that you make your conditions for
failure clear to yourself and people
don't like that.
So if you keep yourself in the fog,
then you can't tell when you screwed up.
Now that isn't so good because you're
still screwing up.
You're just to blind self blind to
notice.
Although in in,
in the short term that's less painful.
If you make your criteria for success
are razor sharp,
then you know every time you screw up,
but that's great because then you could
fix it.
You could either repair the,
the,
the behavioral inadequacy or that
conceptual inadequacy that you're using
as a tool in that situation.
Or maybe you could adjust your damn plan
either way you can fix it and so,
okay,
so you're living in one of these bloody
things and you might as well it seems to
me you might as well make it the best
one you could live in because you don't
have anything better to do.
Now,
if you don't do that,
if you don't do it consciously,
and this is what the psychoanalyst
pointed out,
is that you have innumerable quasi
autonomous subsystems that make you up,
that will generate stories impulsively,
and you'll just act them out.
And you know that because you watch
yourself over two weeks and you think,
Jesus,
I did a lot of stupid things in the last
two weeks and you think,
why?
And it's because you're a random here,
collection of somewhat random,
quasi autonomous personality units and
lacking a leader.
They're just going to fire off whenever
they want.
You know,
first you're hungry,
then you're thirsty.
Then you want to go to bed with your
wife,
you know,
then you want to sleep in and you want
to tell your boss off.
Then you want to curse at the guy that
cuts you off in traffic.
It's like you're kind of like a two year
old,
you know,
just it's one emotional frame after
another vying for dominance.
There's no overarching hierarchy and
there's no king at the top.
And so,
you know,
we already talked about pyramids of
competence in what's supposed to be at
the top is you want to bring all those
things together.
We understand this neurologically.
I'll show you some of that in a little
bit.
We understand this neurologically how,
how,
how this maps some sense right?
Onto the neural structure of your being.
You want to put something in control and
the thing that you should put in control
is the bloody thing that pays attention
and learns,
right?
Everything else in the hierarchy should
be subordinate to the thing that pays
attention and learns and you could
think,
well,
that's.
That's the message of the idea of logos.
That's for sure,
because logos is partly attention and
partly communication and you learn a lot
by communicating with others.
Okay,
so you need to know where you are.
Just like your gps,
which has both.
The closest thing we have to an
intelligent cybernetic system.
Those gps is in your cars.
Those bloody things are pretty smart
because they can.
They knew where you are,
they know where you're going,
and if you go off course,
they recalculate you're route.
It's like those things are damn near
alive.
That's so close to intelligence.
It's and you can tell that because they
act intelligent,
that they solve problems continually.
So you need,
and this is a cybernetic model by the
way,
and cybernetic models where the models
on which the GPS systems were based so
it's not accidental.
So you need to know where you are and
you need to know where you're going and
then the next thing you need to know is
how it is that you're going to act,
move your body,
how you're going to propel yourself
through time and space to transform this
into that.
And so,
okay.
And then we can,
we can make that a little bit more
complex because it's a bit too simple.
So we'll do this.
So it isn't exactly that.
You live in one of these,
it's that you live in a nested hierarchy
of these and you could think of this as
your own internal patriarchy.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And maybe it could be a tyrant or maybe
it could be something that gives you
security and functional autonomy.
And hopefully that's the one you go for.
But it's a battle,
you know,
because a little bit of tyranny exists
in everyone and so well.
So at the very highest level of
analysis,
so that would be the overarching story.
Maybe you think I'd like to be a good
person or a successful person,
famous person.
I think goods probably be better because
you can come up with the definition of
good if you want as long as it doesn't
annoy other people too badly because
they'll just get in your way and that
will be helpful.
So you have to negotiate it.
But let's say you're a good person and
sort of the story at the top of the
hierarchy and then you could depo
decompose that into your primary roles.
Maybe you're a good parent,
maybe you're a good employer or maybe
you're a good employee.
Maybe you're a good sibling.
Maybe you're a good child,
you know,
those are major roles that you have in
your life.
And so you'd say that what good person
is,
is what's good about you across all
those roles.
So it's,
it's a,
it's a higher order abstraction from
something more concrete.
And then you can take the,
you know,
the,
the role,
good parent.
And you can say,
well,
what is it that constitutes a good
parent?
And you might say,
well,
a good parent,
this isn't exhaustive,
obviously a good parent has a good job
and,
and takes
care of his or her family.
And then he might say,
well what does it mean to take care of
your family?
And then you might say,
well,
you know,
you,
you can cook the odd meal,
not too odd.
Hopefully you can cook the meal and you
can play with play with the baby.
And then you might say,
well how do you play with a baby?
And then he might say,
well,
you play peekaboo with the baby or you
tickle the baby.
Okay,
well then what's a cool,
there's a cool shift there because this
is all articulated and conceptual,
right?
Right down to this level.
And then all of a sudden it's your body
because how do you play peekaboo with a
baby?
You don't like have a chat about how you
play peekaboo with a baby,
right?
You go like this.
It was quite sudden you can even do it
with older people.
They even smile about it,
right?
It's dad's gone and the babies all
shocked to death about that.
Where'd he go?
Oh look,
he's back.
You know,
it's the baby is playing with the
reliability of the world,
so it's real intense game for a baby.
It's like,
it's like we're now.
Dad's gone and oh look.
He showed up again.
Oh no,
he's gone.
And then dad smiling to indicate that
those brief flashes into nonexistence
aren't existentially terrifying beyond
capacity.
Right?
And so,
but the point is is that if you're
playing peekaboo with the baby,
you're not thinking anymore.
It's not in the realm of articulation or
abstraction.
It's actually something that you're
doing with your body.
And so to me,
this is a nice multistage solution to
the mind body problem because what
happens is the highest,
the higher order of obstruction,
it's articulated and conceptual,
but if you decompose it sufficiently,
you end up with an actual action.
And the action involves the movement of
musculature.
It's not something conceptual.
And one of the things that's really cool
about this hierarchy is that it has
educational lessons.
So one of the things you want to do if
you're trying to teach someone
something,
even yourself is you want to,
you want to specify the thing that needs
to be doing at the highest resolution
possible level.
So I'll give you just a brief example.
So let's say I may have read maybe
repeating this,
but it doesn't matter.
Say you've got a three year old kid and
they're in their room is chaos,
right?
There's monsters are going to be coming
out under the bed in no time flat unless
that thing room get some order in it.
And so you,
you tell the kid,
clean up the room,
you know it's a mess and you leave and
you come back.
And the kid's like throwing legos
everywhere.
It's,
they're not cleaning up and then you
think that's a bad kid.
But I had some bad theory because you're
going right from here to here.
If you want to have a good fight with
someone and destroy them,
then that's what you do.
You don't bother with the subtleties
down here.
You just go right from the right for the
juggler.
It's like you're a bad,
stupid kid.
You've always been that way.
You're hopeless.
There's not a chance of teaching you
anything.
Right?
And we can.
That way you can nail the past,
the present,
and the future,
all of the same insults.
You've always been a terrible person.
You're,
there's no teaching you and your future
is going to be exactly the same way.
Then the only thing that person can do
if you do that to the missile hit you
because that's,
that's it.
There's no,
there's no coming back from that.
You boxed them completely.
And so if you want to have a really
unproductive argument,
you go right for this past,
present and future that you're not a
good person.
Demolish their entire conceptual
structure and expose them completely
naked to chaos.
It's like great,
you won the argument.
It's not a good thing to do to your
longterm partner,
let's say,
unless you want them terrified out of
their skull and,
uh,
characterized and their attitude towards
you characterized by nonstop extreme
resentment,
it's probably not going to do your love
life.
A hell of a lot of good,
for example.
So with the three year old,
maybe what you do is you say you,
you,
you pick the level of analysis at which
they're actually functioning and you
say,
and this is something you can do if you
pay attention to a kid,
and lots of people won't pay attention
to children because they're terrified of
them.
They're terrified that they'll do
something wrong with them and or the
that the kid won't like them or some
damn thing.
It's like all you have to do to get a
kid to like you is pay attention to the
kid for like two seconds and the kid
will instantly like you because
attention is so.
It's such a.
it's,
it's the ultimate currency for children,
right?
They,
they,
they need adult attention because adults
know way more than kids and so they love
attention.
All you have to do is pay attention to
them.
They will like you instantly.
So can you tell the kid,
you see that teddy bear?
The kid goes,
yes.
Then you've established that the child
has mastered the art of perceiving a
teddy bear because they can say yes.
It's,
it's complicated thing,
man.
It's like a six month old isn't going to
do that.
Three month old has got the whole teddy
bear identification.
Sub Routine.
Automatized.
So teddy bear.
Yes.
Can you pick it up?
Pat.
Pat,
pat.
Good work.
Do you see the hole on that shelf?
Yes.
Can you put the teddy bear in that
whole?
Yes.
Go over.
Do that.
Pat.
Pat,
pat.
Great.
Okay.
Now we'll do thing number two,
thing number three.
So you're building up the micro routines
of cleaning up the room from the bottom
up right here.
You're building it into their body
because you're starting with the things
they've already automatized and building
upwards towards abstraction.
And so once the kid has all the micro
routines down and maybe there's A.
I don't know how many micro routines are
there to clean up your room.
200,
like a lot but not an infinite number.
So you teach them all the micro routines
and then you can say run sat of micro
routines,
which means clean up room and then they
can do it.
They know what it means.
So.
But you do the building from the bottom
up and lots of times when you're arguing
with someone that you live with and
hypothetically love,
although those two things are hard to
get together in the same relationship.
Um,
what you want to do is assume is assume
stupidity before you assume total,
total malevolence.
That's,
that's,
that's a good rule of thumb for
establishing peace.
So maybe if your won't do something,
well maybe it's,
there's something going on up here,
but you might want to assume to begin
with,
they actually just don't know how to do
it and you need to decompose it.
So maybe there's a way you want to be
greeted when you come home because
you're going to come home everyday
probably.
And maybe that's a five minute
interaction or a 10 minute interaction.
So that's an hour a week or four hours a
month or 50 hours a year or one solid
work week of coming home interactions.
Right?
All you have to do is get 50
interactions like that.
Right?
And you've got your relationships sorted
out.
If that's something that's really worth
thinking about because that's it.
There's,
you just don't have that much time,
right,
to get the meals sorted out.
That's about five hours a day,
get your sleeping time arrangements
sorted out,
get the fundamental interactions that
you repeat with your partner,
uh,
worked out voluntarily and negotiated
you're going to cover 80 percent of your
life that way,
and then it can just run as a routine
and that's really helpful.
And if you don't do that consciously,
especially because our roles have
fragmented in most of the traditional
roles of disappeared.
And so nobody knows who the hell is
supposed to do what in the kitchen for
example.
So nobody does anything except bitch and
fight and make wretched meals or,
or by or by a fast food or some
something like that.
So you know,
the,
the alternative to that catastrophic
failure or continual resentment and
fighting is to rebuild the structures
from the bottom up,
using consensus in negotiation.
And,
and you can do that so that you can
think of that as the patriarchal
structure.
That's a good one.
And I mean,
it's partly psychological because these
are things you do as a person,
but it's also partly political and
economic and sociological because while
you're doing each of these things,
you're also doing them in a way that
socially,
hopefully not just socially acceptable
but actually socially desirable.
And so that's,
that's the decomposition.
And the reason that this keeps chaos at
bay is because it isn't because of your
belief systems keep chaos at bay.
It's not that abstract.
It's that if you do things right,
do these things right,
then terrible things happened to you
with less frequency.
And that's not cycle.
Like it's partly psychological because
maybe you don't fight as much.
Maybe you're not as anxious as much.
Maybe you're not as depressed,
but a lot of it's just practical.
If you just,
if you,
you know,
if your kid doesn't leave his skateboard
on the stairs,
then you don't break your neck as often.
And that's not just psychological,
that's actually a good thing not to
break your neck so often.
And so this structure isn't merely
something that keeps things at bay
psychologically.
Okay?
So here's a,
here's another look at a hierarchy of,
of narrative,
the structure that keeps chaos at bay
and this is maybe the hierarchy that I
engage in when I'm writing and I'm doing
all these things at the same time.
Now that's what's cool.
You know,
like when I ask students what are you
doing when you write an essay?
It's like,
well that's hard question,
right?
It's like while you're fasted,
important question,
that's the first thing you should do.
If you're writing an essay,
then you're paying attention to the
words and the phrases and the sentences
and the sentence relationship between
the sentences within the paragraphs and
the paragraph relationships to one
another within the essay and then they
say relevance to the class and the class
has relevance to your life and like the
essay bleeds out across your entire
life.
And so if I'm writing something,
well obviously at the most highest
resolution level of analysis,
I'm actually moving my fingers on the
keyboard and moving my eyes back and
forth on the screen.
That's where the mind meets the body.
But then I'm trying to formulate a
sentence and so I tried to think up a
good sentence that's,
that's nailing what I am trying to
formulate and then I tried to pick it
apart and I do that a bunch of ways.
I take the sentence and I put it on
another page and then I write like 10
different variants of the sentence and
see if I can get a better variant.
And then I try to think of ways that
it's a stupid sentence to see if I can,
you know,
put a pry bar underneath it and loosen
it up.
And if I can't do anything,
if I can't manage that and I keep the
sentence that I've got and then I do
that with 10 sentences in a paragraph
and I make sure the sentences are all
arranged properly in the paragraph the
same way by rewriting a bunch of
different variants of it and trying to
get the word right and the phrase right
and the sentence right.
And the sentence order right.
And the paragraph order.
Right.
And I can tell what it's right enough
because I can't make it any better.
That doesn't mean it's right,
it just means I can't improve it.
And so I get to the point where if I'm
writing a paragraph and I write a
variant and I can't tell if their
variant is any better and it might be
worse than I'm done,
I've hit the limit of my intellectual
capacity and it's time to move on.
But then,
but it isn't like the essay that I'm
writing,
let's say has a boundary.
It's tightly drawn around the essay
because there's a reason I'm writing the
day I'm an essay and that would be.
Well I'm trying to.
I'm trying to write a whole manuscript.
Hopefully I'm trying to address an
important problem because why would I be
doing it otherwise?
I mean that'd be kind of pointless.
And maybe that's part of my role as a
scientist and that's a subset of my role
as a professor.
And then that's a subset of my role as a
productive citizen.
And then that's a subset of my role of
someone who confronts the unknown.
See?
And that's why the logos is the thing
that's at the top of the hierarchy.
That's how the hierarchy should be
structured is that everything else
should be see because you have a
structure and you think,
well,
what should the structure be subordinate
to,
and then the answer should be something
like the structure should be subordinate
to the process that generates the
structure or the structure should be
subordinate to the process that
generates and maintains the structure.
Well obviously how could it be any other
way unless the structures perfect when
in which case you dispense with the
thing that generates it and improves it,
but then you're a totalitarian.
It's like,
Hey,
we got the answer.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
People are still suffering and they're
still dying.
You don't have the damn answer,
and so maybe you have an answer.
That means that there isn't quite as
much suffering and dying as there could
be,
but there's plenty of road to be
traveled yet and so that all makes
perfect sense that all of this should
be,
should be nested within this highest.
I think of it sort of as the highest
order of moral striving and then that
also gives you a moral hierarchy.
That's the most important thing.
You do that with artists speech.
You do that with attention and honest
speech.
That's how you do that and you don't
sacrifice that to any of this because if
you do then then you're hurting your
soul.
It's there's the idea in the new
testament that the sin against the Holy
Ghost is the one sin that can't be
forgiven.
No one knows what the hell that means.
Maybe it doesn't mean anything,
but I think this is what it means is
that because this process generates all
this,
if you violate that process,
then there's no hope for you because
that's the process by which you improve
yourself and everyone else to everything
else.
So if you decide you're not going to
engage in that,
it's like,
well,
there's no fixing that because you've
blown apart your relationship with the
thing that does the fixing and so okay,
and so that's how you keep chaos at bay.
And so part of that is structural,
right?
Because you know how to do these things
more or less,
it's part of your skill set.
If you happened to be a writer,
you could build one of these for a
plumber.
It doesn't.
Doesn't make any difference really.
Although the outside things should be
the same,
which is I think partly why in the Judeo
Christian tradition,
there's the assumption that people are
fundamentally equal before God and what
that means is that,
well,
they should be a nested everyone
regardless of their particularities,
particularities as individuals.
Their highest order function is that
they do it in whatever manner they can
manage and that's an extraordinarily
valuable or maybe the most
extraordinarily valuable sociological,
political and economic function,
and so that's why people are valuable.
It's like we have this faculty to
continually generate improvements to the
structure that we jointly inhabit.
Great.
That gives us.
It's so cool because that gives us a
fundamental unity.
We've got the highest order of of
analysis with with the room for as much
diversity as you can possibly manage.
Right?
Because it actually turns out that the
more the substructures differ,
the better.
Because then you know you can be doing
something different than me.
Now that would be good because if we're
doing the same thing,
then it's just duplication of labor.
If we could agree on the higher order
principle and then specialize at the
lower order levels,
it's like that's you get to have your
cake and eat it too,
and that doesn't happen very often.
So,
so and so.
Then another rule of thumb is if you're
trying to solve a problem,
solve it at this level,
highest resolution level possible before
you dare move up,
dare move up the hierarchy because the,
as you move up the abstraction
hierarchy,
the probability that you'll make a
catastrophic error while attempting to
fix the problem radically increases
because abstraction is very,
very powerful.
And so you want to be very careful.
I mean we saw that when you know,
when the,
when the mortgage market crashed,
the reason it crashed was because of
strange use of derivatives and
derivatives are like higher order
abstractions in the financial world and
derivatives give you tremendous
financial leverage and power with huge
risk.
And so the upside is massive.
Absolutely massive because you can
multiply your earnings,
but the downside is complete bloody
catastrophe and so part of what I would
say an intelligent,
conservative ethos is,
is solve the problem at the highest
level of resolution,
highest level,
local,
most local level of resolution.
It's safer and it's more likely to
actually produce a solution.
Okay,
now,
so now you're in your plan.
Now we've simplified it again just to
one little map,
right?
But all those other things are nested in
there.
And so what happens to you as you stroll
merrily on your way through life?
Well,
what happens is that as you're moving
from point a to point b,
you encounter things and people think
that what they encounter are objects,
but that's not the case.
First of all,
most of the things that you encounter,
many of the things are actually other
people and they're not objects.
They're too damn complex.
And even apart from the social world,
the things that you encounter aren't
objects.
They seem to be something more like
tools or obstacles.
And I don't mean that we see objects and
turn them into tools or obstacles.
I mean that we see tools and obstacles
because what happens is that when new
array yourself towards a goal,
then the world transforms itself into
things that get in the way of that goal
and things that three things,
things that get in the way of the goal,
things.
Those are things you don't like.
Things that facilitate your movement
towards the goal.
Those are things that you like and
irrelevant things and mostly you want
irrelevant things because there's just
too damn many things,
so the category of irrelevant is when
you really like.
So most of the things,
most of everything is irrelevant.
If you have a good plan,
a few things are good because they move
you forward and some other things are
not so good.
You want to go around the not so good
things.
If you can manage them,
unless you'd like to run head forth into
like brick walls,
which is not particularly so learning
experience,
but I wouldn't repeat it too many times.
You want,
you want the world to array itself as a
set of.
We could say tools.
Now what happens is that you have this
perceptual system that's mediated by
dopamine.
It's the same system that cocaine
activates or methamphetamine or the
drugs that people really like to,
and it's the dopaminergic system that
responds with positive emotion to
indications that you've encountered
something that will facilitate your
movement towards a goal,
and that's really important to know
because people tend to think that
they're happy because they achieve goals
and that's not true what's true,
because as soon as you achieve a goal,
then you have a problem which is what's
the next goal,
and that's actually a big problem.
You encounter that as soon as you
graduate from university for example.
That's right.
I made this joke before they graduation
day yours like king of the university
hierarchy,
undergraduate hierarchy day after you're
unemployed,
potential starbucks employee.
Right?
So it's like.
So obviously the,
the,
the accomplishment per se as a source of
reward is,
is problematic because when you
accomplish,
you run the,
the frame to its end and then you have
the problem of needing a new frame.
So that's a problem.
But if what you're encountering instead
are things that will move you along your
way,
it's like,
hey,
that's great and that's where you get
your positive motivation and so that's
really thinking.
That's so much we're thinking about.
You can think about that for a year and
that wouldn't even be enough to think
about it because here's what it means.
It means in some sense that the
Buddhists are right with their claim
about Maya M,
a y a,
which means that people live in an
illusion and what they mean by that is
while you have goal,
whatever your goal is,
and that goal gives relevance to the
world and you could change the relevance
of the world and the snap just by
changing your goal,
you can do that.
And so then you think,
well,
it's sort of an illusion because you can
just change it.
Now.
You don't want to push that line of
argumentation too far because even if
the specific point can be changed,
the fact that you're in one of these
frames cannot be changed.
And so you have to be in a frame.
Although you get to pick the frame.
So there's still an absolute there,
which is that you have to be in a frame
and that is not a trivial absolute.
It's a very.
It's a very major absolute.
So then you think,
okay,
all of your positive emotion is going to
be experienced in relationship to the
goal.
Well then we think,
well you could use some positive
emotion.
It's a good thing.
Positive emotion inhibits anxiety and
disappointment and frustration and pain.
It does all that.
Technically it does that.
That's why a football player with broken
thumb who wants to score a touchdown can
go out there and you know,
play the football game,
even though it's a kind of an arbitrary
goal,
right?
It's like,
really you're going to go out there and
risk your hand to fire a pigskin through
some,
some polls.
So like,
well you can say the same sort of
cynical thing about most of the things
that people do,
but you can't say the cynical thing
about the fact that they have to do
things.
So you have a,
you have a point,
you have your aim,
you have your ambition,
and then that's what turns the world
into a potentially positive place.
And here's the kicker.
This is so cool.
The higher they aim,
the more of the positive emotion.
So that's,
that's you think,
well why should I bother?
Why should I bother doing something
lofty and difficult?
It's like because it's worth it.
That's why.
Because the alternative is stupid
suffering because really,
really,
because what happens is like you don't
need a framework in order to suffer.
You can just lay there day after day and
suffer,
right?
That's easy.
So that's the default condition.
If you don't have a lofty ambition,
then you suffer miserably.
And the reason for that is life is
really complex,
short,
finite,
full of suffering and beyond you.
And so you can just lay there and think
about that and it's horrible.
And so that's not helpful.
It's just not useful.
And so,
you know,
people often say life is meaningless.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
That's wrong.
Because it was meaningless.
That'd be easy.
You could just sit there and do nothing.
And it wouldn't matter,
right?
It'd be like you were lobotomized.
Sheep is just irrelevant.
But that isn't what happens when people
say that life has no meaning.
That isn't what they mean.
What they mean is I'm suffering stupidly
and intensely and I don't know what to
do about it.
Well,
the suffering is meaningful.
It's just dark,
the kind of meaning you want.
So how do you get out of that?
You adopt you,
you,
you note the baseline of suffering,
which is very,
very,
very high.
And then you say to yourself,
okay,
I need to do something that justifies
that.
And that's not so easy because it's the
baseline for suffering is high.
If you're going to make something of
yourself,
let's say,
so that it's worthwhile to exist in the
world,
then you have to do.
You have to aim at something that's so
well structured that you can say,
yeah,
earthquakes,
cancer,
death of my family,
dissolution of my goals,
ultimate futility of life,
and the heat,
death of the universe.
Hey,
it doesn't matter.
It's worth it.
All right,
so now here's an here's another
complicating factor.
So I said,
well,
there's three things that you can run
into when you're going about your your
goal.
Now I would say if you're going to form
a goal,
if you're going to form a plan,
look about three to five years out in
the future because beyond that you get
something called commentorial explosion
and it means that there's so many
variables that you just can't predict.
So there's not that much point looking
out 20 years because like what the hell
do you know what's going to happen in 20
years?
Nothing.
Three years.
Maybe you've got,
maybe you can chart a course to three
years,
five years,
something like that.
So that's not a bad segment of time too
to consider and then consider what your
life would have to be like in order for
it to be worthwhile for you.
Knowing also what you're going to be
like if it isn't worthwhile for you and
what you're going to be like if it isn't
worthwhile for you is cane.
That's what you're like.
Because that's what that story's about.
Because Abel is the guy who has a goal
in this making the proper sacrifices and
Cain is the person for whom by his own
faults,
at least in part,
things aren't working out for.
And so the default for not doing this is
something like building resentment,
bitterness with an underlying,
what would you call it,
flavor enhancer of murderous resentment,
something like that,
which you will act out in the world
which people act out in the world all
the time.
And it's no wonder because without this,
without something lofty pulling you
along than the baseline is stupid
suffering.
And you know,
if you take an animal,
a dog and you just change it in the
backyard,
you know when you put a collar on it,
there's too tight.
So it chafes all the time and it can't
even bark and you know,
there's just dirt around it.
It's too God damn hot out in the sun and
maybe you don't give it enough water,
you know,
it's not going to be very happy dog.
It's basic condition is misery.
Well the same applies to people.
So.
All right,
so you're on your way to see you
remember the survey.
You've all probably watched Pinocchio or
know about it.
One of the things that happens that's
really cool in Pinocchio is that when
Joe Decides that he wants his puppet to
be a genuine autonomous being,
he wishes upon a star.
It's a very strange thing,
but everybody just swallows it because
we don't notice when we're swallowing
things that are that are completely
preposterous.
You know it's this animated puppeteer
wishes on a star that is puppet is going
to become real,
and everybody nodded their head and
goes,
oh yeah,
that makes sense.
It's like,
no,
it doesn't.
It doesn't make any sense at all,
but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't make the sort of sense that
we normally associate with sense.
It makes it kind of medicines and
everybody understands it.
So this is what your pedal is doing is
he's elevating his eyes above the
horizon.
So out of the realm of the worldly,
let's say,
to the transcendent and the transcendent
will say,
for all intents and purposes,
you can see the transcendent spread
above you in,
in,
in the heaven that arches over us.
It's,
it's close enough for our purposes,
and there's a star there and it started
something that's eternal,
that shines in the darkness.
And so Japan makes an agreement with the
transcendent.
He says,
look,
I'm willing to do whatever it takes that
my creation becomes autonomous.
While that's exactly the situation that
you want to set up for yourself is like,
okay,
you got to figure out what star you're
going to orient yourself by and you have
to ask yourself like no one's ever asked
you.
Okay,
if you had the choice to make your life
worth living,
what's your price?
What do you need?
Just find out.
First of all,
you ask,
you'll tell yourself like you'll be
afraid because he thought,
I'll never get that.
It's like,
well,
lower your sights a little bit.
Then you know,
don't ask for a 80 foot super yacht in
like six months.
That just means you're stupid.
It doesn't mean you're not.
First of all,
it's not going to make you happy
anyways.
You know,
it's just not.
It's not.
It's not wise.
You're asking,
you're supposed to be asking yourself
this question like you're someone you
care about.
So you imagine you're talking to some 12
year old kid that you kind of like
think,
I wouldn't be so bad if this 12 year old
kid at a decent life.
So Youtube,
it's like,
it wouldn't be so bad.
The universe wouldn't mind if you had a
decent life if there was little less
suffering on your part,
specially if you didn't,
you know,
foisted off on other people.
If there's a little less suffering on
your part and you made things a little
better everywhere you went,
it's like the universe would probably be
okay with that.
So you could.
I think you could get away with it if
you're a sort of quiet about it.
And so now ask yourself,
okay,
so then once you've established your
target and you know where you are,
then you know what's good for you
because that moves you along.
And that happens at a perceptual level,
you don't have to think about it anymore
and the experimental literature and now
it's already quite clear.
So for example,
if I specify that podium as the target
for my action,
you know,
then I'm happy when I'm walking towards
it because there it is in everything
cooperating really nicely.
Then if I specify going to the exit sign
that you guys can't see,
that's that,
that,
that this is an obstacle in the front
of.
Then as soon as I specify that,
then that's an annoying obstacle.
And that's pre-cognitive.
It's happens immediately.
It happens instantaneously.
And so it really is the case that you,
you,
you're,
you're being manifests itself inside
these frames.
And so what's so cool about that is you
can change the frame.
It doesn't mean you can like juggle
planets or anything like that,
but it does give you quite a scope of,
of,
of what untrammeled action within the
world.
And if the frame isn't working out then
you can tweak it.
Or sometimes you have to make a major
adjustment in it,
whatever.
You don't have to stick to the damn
thing like it's the ideology that you're
going to die for.
It's attended of plan,
it's a work in progress and it's,
and that's with the future authoring
program.
One of the things I recommend for people
is that they should do it badly because
you're not going to get it right
anyways,
but a reasonable plan is way better than
no plan.
Plus a reasonable plan is a plan that
has built into it.
The processes that will enable the plan
to get better as you implement it,
so you just start with a reasonable plan
so you don't have to worry about whether
it's correct,
it's not correct,
doesn't matter.
It's better than nothing.
That's the issue.
So okay,
so you've got the world parsed up into
things that are making or making you
happy when you look at them,
things that get in the way that produce
negative emotion and then a whole host
of irrelevant things because almost
everything is irrelevant and that's
where all the chaos is hiding.
The chaos is hiding in what's irrelevant
and so,
and that's very interesting observation
because since the chaos is virtually
infinite,
it's a real questions.
Where the hell do you put it while you
put it in,
what you ignore and you can ignore it as
long as it isn't actively interfering
with your movement forward,
you can assume that it's,
that it doesn't matter that it doesn't
matter that it doesn't matter.
Same thing.
All right?
So here's the kicker.
There's one more class of things that
you can run into along the way and this
is where the chaos breaks through.
So let's say
you're moving from point a to point b
and something that you don't expect
occurs and it gets in the way.
So let's say that you're living with
someone and maybe you kind of like them.
You're not married so you don't like
them that much because otherwise you'd
ask them to marry you.
But anyways.
Um,
and so a quarter view is looking for
something better and three quarters view
is half satisfied,
something like that.
And then a person because we're
ambivalent about such things.
And then the person you discover or the
person announces that they've been
having an affair.
Okay.
So then how are you supposed to respond
emotionally to that?
Well,
the part of you that wasn't all that
committed to the relationship is kind of
exhilarated by that.
And then the three quarters of you
that's half satisfied is hurt and,
and you're going to exploit that part
for sure in the ensuing discussions and
not mention the,
oh,
that's kind of exciting that you've
betrayed me that way.
So,
so,
but the point is,
is that you,
that's a whole.
Now what's happened is a whole has you
have this structure that you're walking
on ice,
like the thin ice that you're skating on
and now there's a hole in it and the
whole,
we don't even know how deep the hole is,
but you know there's a hole there and so
now you're anxious about it.
Oh,
they'll maybe also a little bit excited
because God only knows what's down
there,
but,
but you don't know what to do with that
whole because it could spread very badly
on you.
It could be that you know the whole
relationship was a facade and that all
your relationships have been facades,
facades,
and that the reason that is is because
you're so damn shallow that it's
impossible for you to have a
relationship that isn't just a facade
and that's partly because you don't pay
any attention to other people and it's
also partly because you're malevolent
and selfish,
so that's a nasty thing to discover or
maybe that's the sort of person that
you're attracting,
which would make sense actually,
if that's the sort of person that you
are and so,
so there are certain things that you can
encounter that basically unglue you,
and what happens is that those moments
of being unglued travel up that entire
hierarchy of presuppositions.
It's like because the one of the logical
conclusions to being betrayed in a
relationship is that you are,
that you're truly a bad person.
Now another equally logical conclusion
is that the person that you're with is
really a bad person,
and another logical conclusion is all
people are truly bad people.
You know,
I mean in,
in,
in macro ways,
at,
in microwaves.
You can't trust anyone.
You can't trust women.
You can't trust men.
You can't trust human beings.
You can't trust yourself.
The whole place is a catastrophe.
It's a nightmare.
Well,
then you can fall through into chaos.
Now the way your body responds to that,
when some,
or maybe you know you're supposed to be
getting a promotion at work,
that's good.
You're all chipper about the promotion
at work and you,
you walk into your boss's office because
he or she wants to see you and they say,
well,
you know,
we've reviewed your performance over the
last few years and your performance has
been somewhere between mediocre and
decent and we're downsizing and see you
later.
That's not a raise or a promotion,
that's for sure.
That's a whole that you fall into and
the question is,
well,
what do you make of that?
Right?
How do you frame that?
How do you take that emergent chaos and
make habitable order out of?
You don't know.
Is the whole capitalist system rotten to
the core?
I mean,
that's a convenient explanation under
those circumstances.
That's for sure.
Where you're working for a psychopathic
son of a bitch,
did you make the wrong choice in
university and was that your father's
fault because you never did what you
wanted or was it your fault for not
standing up to them or is it a dying
industry or is maybe there's a wake up
call that you should go do something
else that you've been waiting to do you
know that you've actually wanted to do
your whole life and that's why you're
doing such a miserable job at your
current occupation because you're bitter
and resentful about the fact that you
never did what you want.
You don't know.
It's all of those things at once and
that's very stressful because all of
those things at once is too many things
and that's the reemergence of chaos.
That's the flood.
That's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos.
That's another way that it's been
represented.
Ms Dot biologically.
Instead you voyage all the way back to
the beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is.
I mean that that can really,
that can be traumatizing and it can hurt
your brain,
you know it's just too much for you to
bear,
but it doesn't matter.
You're stuck with it,
and so how do you respond to that?
Well,
some of it is catastrophic negative
emotion.
You freeze and that's protective and
maybe you don't even want to move.
You don't want to bloody well get out of
bed for a week and that's because your
body is reacting as if the bedroom floor
is covered with snakes and the best
thing for you to do is just not move,
just freeze.
Not a pleasant situation to be in
because it's your hyperaroused very,
very physiologically demanding and
there's zero about it that's productive
except maybe the snakes won't see you,
but they've already seen you,
so that isn't helping very well.
So you've got all this undifferentiated
native,
negative emotion,
anxiety,
fear,
hurt,
anger,
guilt,
shame,
emotional pain,
the whole plethora of catastrophes.
And then maybe on the other side lurking
down there is,
thank God I'm done with that job.
I just bloody well hated.
I dragged myself off to work every day
and there's a little part of my soul
that so goddamn happy.
I finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it.
You know,
maybe you don't even admit that to
yourself because.
Well,
that would mean that all that time you
spent at the job was just sunk costs.
You're diluting yourself the whole time.
I.
It is an interesting thing to consider
those sometimes if you're in the
unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone,
you know,
sometimes firing someone is the best
thing that can happen to them,
which doesn't mean that you should go
out and like enjoy it.
Although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people and I'll tell you a story about
that at some point because it's quite
interesting,
but you know,
sometimes if someone's just limping
along in their job and doing it as
miserably in wretchedly as they possibly
can,
imagine,
the best thing you can do to them for
the ms dot say,
you know,
you're failing at this and,
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
you would have to be failing at
absolutely everything else.
In the entire world,
so maybe you should just accept the dam
failure and go off and try something new
and I mean that's terrifying for people
and I know they hate it and all that,
but,
but sometimes it's better than the
alternative,
which is just slow,
torturous death.
So
here's a funny way of looking at it.
So let's say you fall right into that
hole that's underneath any everything
and you've hit an anomaly that you don't
understand.
You say,
what's that anomaly made out of?
Exactly.
I know that's a strange way of thinking
about it,
you know,
because it's not.
Well you could say we'll just go along
with that.
It's a metaphor.
What's that anomaly made out at?
Well here's a way of thinking about it.
It's made out of spirit and matter.
And here's why.
This is something I learned in part from
Piaget said,
well,
it's made out of matter because of
course that's the world matter and the
world is also what matters.
And so that's kind of a nice duality
there,
but it's made out of spirit because when
you encounter something anomalous and go
down the rabbit hole,
when you go into the underworld that's
underneath everything that you've relied
on,
you learn things down there.
So what's down there is information and
that now it's moved maybe way more
information than you want,
but it is information.
It's information and what can you.
What can you do with the information?
You can inform yourself with the
information,
right?
You can put yourself information with
the information that's helpful too.
And so and you think,
well you,
you're a psyche.
Maybe you're not a spirit.
It depends on whether you're a
materialist or not,
but at least we can say that you're a
psyche.
The question is,
what's your psyche made of all?
It's obviously got a material substrate,
but the the matter happens to be a raid
in,
in a particular order and that's an
information order.
And so when you fall into the underworld
that's underneath everything and you
encountered that latent information than
what you can do is enhance your psyche.
You can grow your spirit because what
you do is you take the new information
and you incorporate it.
That's like eating the apple that that
Adam and eve ate.
You incorporate that and that makes more
of you and that's not a metaphorical or
metaphysical proposition.
It's not to say nothing other than well,
that's what happens when children learn
to think of what happens.
Charles three has a pretty low
resolution representations of the world
and is a fairly low resolution human
being.
God all the constituent elements there
but isn't differentiated in any
tremendous manner.
That's all still to come in the future,
and so what does the child do?
Explore,
what are they?
Explore things they don't understand.
That's where the information is because
you already understand what you
understand.
There's no information there.
You go were there where you don't
understand.
That's where the information is,
and out of that information,
you generate a higher resolution world
and you generate a higher resolution
self and so out of the combat with the
underlying dragon of chaos,
you generate spirit and matter and
that's what you do when you go down into
the underworld.
So if it doesn't kill you or if it
doesn't make you wish you were dead,
which it probably will,
but there's a bunch of you that has to
die down there anyways.
So maybe that's not such a bad thing
because if you had this relationship
that ended in betrayal,
then there's something that's not
exactly right.
Right?
There's something that went.
And the reason I'm saying that think,
well that's kind of moralistic.
It's like,
actually I don't mind being moralistic
in case you haven't noticed,
but.
But that's not.
It's not a fair comment because you're
playing this stupid game.
It's like you live with someone in
fidelity.
That's the game,
right?
You decided the rules with the game
comes to morality.
The morality are the rules of the game.
Well then the thing collapses into
infidelity.
It's like,
well,
you played the game wrong,
or it was the wrong game.
One of those to you.
It's one of those two.
You pick the damn game and having picked
the game,
you can't all of a sudden say,
well no,
those aren't the rules.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
If you pick the game,
you picked the rules and if you fail at
complying with the rule,
then you fail.
Now you could say,
well,
I can pick a different game.
It's like,
I don't care how you solve the problem.
You're still stuck with the problem.
It's a moral problem fundamentally,
and it might take some major league
retooling to to fix it.
So you're at point a trying to get to
point b.
that's not working out.
You hit an anomaly,
you're not getting to point B,
that's for sure.
Your medical school student,
you're right,
your m cats,
which is this test.
You have to right to go to medical
school,
you get 25th percentile.
I don't know who you are,
but you're not a premed student and
maybe you never were right?
And that's the rub man,
and so who the hell are you?
You don't know,
collapsed down here into this
motivational conflict,
this place of motivational and emotional
uncertainty and tremendous information,
right?
It's a place of transformation.
It's the phoenix that burns.
It's the burning part of the phoenix
that Burns.
It's.
It's the journey to the underworld.
It's the journey to hell.
It can really be a journey to hell
because you may find out that the reason
that you're partner b trade you or that
you didn't get your damn promotion is
because there's seriously something
wrong with you and you know it and I
don't just mean that you don't know what
you're doing.
I mean that there is 25 percent of you
that has seriously aiming at things not
being good and so you fall into the
underworld and you find out that,
Oh God,
I just got exactly what I was aiming
for.
Or I got exactly what the worst part of
me was aiming for and that worst part,
that's something to clean up and that's
not going to be easy because it's got a
toxin.
Me like something,
something ferocious,
something seriously ferocious and I've
been toying with it for a very long time
and maybe I can't even detach it
anymore.
And so that's not so fun.
And you see people like that in
psychotherapy very frequently or you see
them wandering around on the streets
like absolute catastrophic former shells
of themselves.
You know,
because they've hit the underworld and
they ended up in hell and there's no
getting out of it,
and so those are the people you tend to
give a wide berth to when you walk down
the street.
So there you are down in the underworld,
right back where the latest information
exists in just too much of it.
And that's this.
It's the same thing.
It's the same thing and that's why they
Adam and Eve stories archetipal,
right?
Because we're always ingesting something
new that knocks us into a new state of
self consciousness and it's always a
catastrophic
demolition of our current,
of our previous paradise.
Insufficient as that paradise was,
something comes along to destroy it and
knocks the slots out of our life.
And that's a voyage to the underworld,
out of the walled garden,
into chaos.
And so what is all of that?
Well,
there's lots of ways of construing it.
It's a,
it's a frame transformation.
There is a walled city.
It's got a hole in it because all walled
cities have holes in them,
right?
Because everything's imperfect and
that's where the chaos comes up.
And then maybe you go out there like a
hero to fight the chaos and to
reestablish the frame,
that's what you're supposed to do and
maybe you free some information while
you're doing that or maybe you establish
a relationship and so that's the
frame damage,
chaos,
voluntary confrontation,
reconstitution of the world,
and that's the,
that's human existence.
And hopefully it's not just linear,
it's it's stepwise,
right?
Is that the you that emerges as a
consequence of your latest catastrophe
is everything that you were before plus
something more and that actually
constitutes what you might describe as
measurable progress.
Right?
And that's another argument against
moral relativism because if you can do
everything that you could do before and
you can do some more things,
we could just define that as better.
It's not a bad definition.
And then we have an APP.
It's like what you're trying to do is to
differentiate the world and
differentiate yourself.
And every time you undergo one of these
revolutions,
then hopefully both of those things
happen.
And then there's a moral to that story
too,
which is do it voluntarily and maybe do
it.
Don't wait for it to happen.
Catastrophic.
Really keep your eyes open and when
something goes a little bit wrong that
you could fix,
fix it.
Don't say no,
that doesn't matter.
Maybe it does matter.
Maybe it is matter.
Maybe it's exactly the matter out of
which you should be built.
Maybe it's the matter of which the world
should be built and if part of you is
telling you it matters.
What it means is that that part is
telling you that there's something there
that you need to engage with.
That's what it means for something to
matter.
I really get out of the kicker.
I can't go out of the word matter
because it's got these two weird
meetings,
right?
There's the matter that everything is
made out of that materialists think.
Everything is made out of and that's
just dead matter and then there's the
matter that life is made out of which is
what matters and now and then you're
moving through life and something
matters.
It's calling to you and that's the
unrevealed world trying to reveal itself
to you and all you have to do is allow
it to reveal itself to you,
and then maybe what happens is that a
minor share shift in shape is all that
has to happen to you.
You don't have to burn right down to the
bloody egg and and hatch out.
You know,
as a newborn,
maybe you can just repair a little bit
of something that's gone wrong with you
and so you can undergo a sequence of
continual micro deaths instead of
waiting for the bloody catastrophe that
might send you so far down that you'll
never recover.
And now you have to do is it tend to
what matters and your whole nervous
system is doing this for you.
You've got a goal.
Something happens.
It matters.
So what are you supposed to do with
that?
You're supposed to.
You're supposed to fix it.
You're supposed to engage with it.
That's why it's calling out to you as if
it matters.
It's saying there's an indeterminant
part of the world here that wants to
manifest itself into fully articulated
being and it's calling to you to do
that.
And if you ignore
it,
then it accumulates and accumulates,
it turns into the dragon of chaos.
And then it waits until you're not at
your best,
and then it eats you.
And that's the alternative.
So that seems like a bad plan unless you
like being lunchmeat.
So.
So that's a long introduction to noah.
Thank you.
You need it,
you know,
because he can understand the story
otherwise.
And so because that's what the story's
about.
And now we can go through the story
relatively rapidly,
although it doesn't look like we'll go
through all of it tonight.
Okay?
So we'll start with the next section of
Genesis.
And this is immediately after Cain and
Abel and there's a short story to begin
with just to fragment.
I called it giants of the earth and it
came to pass when men began to multiply
on the face of the earth.
So this is after Cain and Abel that and
daughters were born unto them that the
sons of God saw the daughters of men,
that they were fair and took them wives
of all which they chose,
and the Lord said,
my spirit shall not always strive with
man for that he is also flesh.
Yet his days will be 120 years.
There were giants in the earth in those
days.
And also after that,
when the sons of God came in unto the
daughters of men and they bare children
to them,
the same became mighty men were tour of
old men of renown.
Now there's been all sorts of attempts
to interpret those few rather jumbled
blinds.
But I see it as a reflection of a
classic development of hero mythology,
which is,
and this is sort of nostalgia for the
past.
One of the things Mircea Eliana pointed
out was that what happens to human
memory in preliterate cultures because
nothing is written down,
is that what needs to revert,
preserve gets amalgamated.
And so imagine that you have a culture
that's based on fishing would say so you
have to be a good fisherman know,
and a human beings who use simple tools
to fish are unbelievably good fishermen.
They know every bloody thing you can
possibly imagine about fish because
otherwise they die.
So it's really important that they learn
everything about fish and maybe they'd
been fishing for like 13,000
years or something like that.
So there's a lot of accumulated
knowledge.
And so then the question is,
well,
who taught mankind how to fish?
And the answer is fragments of
individuals across history.
But that's,
you know,
you're not gonna.
Remember the damn fragments.
You put them all together into the
amalgam of the heroic fishermen.
You know the guy who established the
pattern for proper fishing,
whatever that pattern happens to be,
one of the patterns might be,
don't take all the damn fish because
there won't be any further next year.
Something that.
But
all those fragments of discovery get
amalgamated into heroes of the past.
And then what you do if you're a
fisherman,
is you act out the heroic fishermen of
the past,
and so the idea that there were men of
renown are heroes in the past is just a
fragmentary,
what would you call?
It's just a fragment of that sequence of
ideas that back in the past there were
mighty human beings who established the
proper patterns of being and they were
the sons of God who took the daughters
of men to wife.
Now,
and it's interesting too,
because we do know that the more
competent men are disproportionately
likely to leave offspring,
so it's a perfectly reasonable way of
formulating the circumstance onto the
flood.
This is from merchant Yada,
who,
who wrote a book called a history of
religious ideas,
which I strongly recommended.
It's a three volume set.
It's quite readable and it's brilliant.
It's brilliant.
I really like it,
and this is what materiality Adis had to
say about flood myths,
as has been well known since the
compilations made by our Andre Age user
and Jg Fraser who wrote the golden
bough.
The Deluge myth of flood mid is almost
universally disseminated.
It is documented on all the continents,
although very rarely in Africa,
particularly in the desert for an
unsurprisingly,
although and on various cultural levels,
a certain number of variants seemed to
be the result of dissemination rather
than spontaneous regeneration,
let's say first for Mesopotamia,
and then from India.
It is equally possible that one or
several dilute catastrophes gave rise to
fabulous narratives,
but it would be risky to explain so
widespread myth by phenomena of which no
geological traces has been found.
Well,
Elliot,
who wrote this quite awhile ago,
I think he wrote that book perhaps in
the eighties,
maybe in the seventies,
but since then,
there actually has been quite a bit of
evidence.
I'm advanced in various circles for the
existence of catastrophic floods that
occurred within the relative memory of
human relative human civilization
memory,
let's say.
So the West Coast Indians,
for example,
I suppose that's the wrong word,
the west coast.
I don't know what to say that I know,
uh,
Kwakwaka'Wakw carver who told me a flood
story and they have a story that's
almost identical to the story of Noah,
except of course it involves giant
canoes,
but it's,
it's the same story they release,
if I remember correctly,
a raisin,
but noaa releases a raven first and then
a dove once,
once the flood comes to an end and it
has a tower of Babel issue to the same
story.
So the canoes are all put together.
It's not one giant canoe.
It's a bunch of canoes altogether.
They write out the flood and then the
canoes separate in and go all over the
world.
And that's why there are people all over
the world.
So anyways,
the story is very disseminated.
But you know,
there were floods in North America not
that long ago.
So there were floods.
You can look up the missoula floods
15,000
to 13,000
years ago.
And the core people have probably been
on the west coast for something like 13
to 14,000
years.
So,
and you know,
you can,
you can maintain an oral tradition for a
very,
very long time,
you think no,
but traditional societies don't change.
That's why they're traditional and so
they have the same stories over
generations.
They,
they remember the same stories.
So when the missoula floods,
which were a consequence of melting
glacial ice discharged up,
they figured there were 55,055
of them between 15,000
and 13,000
years ago,
discharged volumes up to 15 times the
volume of the Amazon River.
So these are major league floods and
then a sears at all,
published a paper in 2008 called climate
change and post glacial human disperses
in Southeast Asia claiming that there
were multiple floods particularly
affecting Southeast Asia between 15,000
and 7,000
years ago.
So there might elliot,
it might be a bit wrong about the notion
that there were no geological traces of
such,
such catastrophic flooding.
But anyways,
it doesn't matter because we're still
looking at this from a psychological
perspective and that's fine.
The majority of the flood myth Siemens
some sense to form part of the cosmic
rhythm.
The old world people by a fallen
humanity is submerged under the waters
and sometime later a new world emerges
from the aquatic chaos in large number
of variants that flood is the result of
the sins or ritual faults of human
beings.
Sometimes it's results simply from the
wish of a divine being to put an end to
mankind.
The chief causes lie at once in the sins
of men and the decrepitude of the world.
It's a brilliant analysis partly because
it puts it.
It draws this lovely parallel between
which are mentioned a bit earlier
between the fact that things go wrong
all by themselves,
but that you can speed that along by not
paying any attention.
You know,
so if you're in a relationship,
you know,
relationship takes an awful lot of
maintenance and you knew what it means
needs to be maintained because you start
developing some distance from the person
that you have the relationship with.
And then that starts to become tinged
with a little bit of dislike and
hopefully not contempt,
but a little bit of dislike and maybe
some,
some emotional distance.
And you feel that and you think,
well,
it's hard tell what you think,
but you feel that anyways,
you know that that's emerged and so then
you have a chance at at that point to
repair whatever's gone wrong.
And that would require some retooling on
both of your parts.
Maybe one more,
one person more than the other,
but whatever.
We would require a serious discussion
like,
look,
I've noticed that this has been
happening and maybe it's you and maybe
it's me and we should probably figure it
out because if it was you,
that'd be convenient and everything.
But if it was me,
then I'd like to fix it because
then it would be fixed.
And so that's why you listen to your
partner because they might tell you that
there's something stupid about you that
you don't know.
And then if you could fix that,
then you wouldn't have to be stupid in
that way anymore.
And it's actually one of the real
useful.
It's one of the genuinely useful
features of having a partner because do
you really want to be stupid?
And then continue to repeat your
mistakes ad Nauseum for the rest of your
life.
I know it's more convenient to do that
than to have a knock down drag out
argument about just exactly why you're
stupid and how you could fix it,
but still it's better to have the
argument.
So the chief causes lie at once in the
sins of man in the decrepitude of the
world and the sins there are generally
either acts of commission where people
do things that they know to be wrong or
they failed to do things that they know
would be right.
It doesn't really matter.
The sins of commission are usually
judged more harshly,
say within the Judeo Christian
tradition.
But I think there might be a bit of an
error in that because sins of omission
can be a real catastrophe.
And so here's a flawed idea.
You tell me what you think about this.
So you know,
so there's this idea that a judgmental
being will flood you out if you continue
on your way word ways.
And that seems like a little bit,
you know,
it's one of the examples of,
of Jehovah being a little on the harsh
side in the Old Testament,
not something that modern people really
a prove of so much because we like our
gods sort of domesticated,
let's put it that way.
And unfortunately that isn't how it
tends to work.
But I've often thought about the
reaction in North America to the
hurricane in,
in New Orleans because there's two ways
of reading that,
right?
One is mother nature
has a little fit and sends a hurricane
into New Orleans and wipes everyone out.
And isn't that a catastrophe?
And isn't that an example of.
Isn't that example of our fragility and
the force in the face of,
of natural power.
But there's another way of reading it.
Maybe this is unfair,
but it'll do for the purposes of
illustration.
It's like,
you know,
the Dutch build dikes,
right to keep the ocean back and they're
actually pretty effective at that
because their country's mostly
underwater.
And it turns out that if you go to
Holland,
it's actually not underwater.
And so they're dikes are working.
And so the Dutch were very organized
people and they better be because their
country is supposed to be underwater,
right?
So you better be organized if your
country is supposed to be underwater.
And so they are very organized and they
have a rule for their dykes,
which is they try to estimate the worst
possible oceanic storm that will come in
10,000
years and made sure that the dikes will
withstand that.
Well from my reading,
the Army Corps of Engineers in New
Orleans build the dikes for a storm
every hundred years and that's not so
good because we live about eight years,
let's say.
So that means the probability that one
of those storms is going come up and buy
in a lifespan is pretty damn high.
And then so that perhaps wasn't the
wisest of planning,
especially because some of New Orleans
is actually supposed to be underwater.
And then worse.
You know,
Mississippi is a state that's quite well
known for its corruption.
And so you might also say that a
tremendous amount of the money and time
and resources that could have and should
have and was planned to go towards
fixing the problem didn't eat,
and so the hurricane came along and Oh
my God wasn't in a natural disaster.
And the question is,
what bloody well makes you so sure that
it was a natural disaster,
right?
Because if the infrastructure would have
been maintained and built to the
specifications that were certainly
technically possible and would have
actually been less expensive in the long
run to build and everyone knew it and
the hurricane came along and wiped build
the city,
why do you think that's a natural
disaster?
To me that's an.
That's a natural example.
If you think about it from a
metaphorical perspective of a judgmental
God deciding to use a flood to teach a
moral lesson,
and you might say,
well,
that's pretty harsh.
What about all those floods survivors?
I care.
Well,
the whole flood thing was kind of harsh
and so pointing out that there were
steps that could have been taken and and
also that I doubt in the aftermath have
been taken even though everyone knows
now exactly what had happened is
you might consider the diagnosis,
but it's irrelevant because what I,
what I'm really trying to tell you is
how the mythological stories would line
up on this because you can tell a story
about mother nature manifesting her kick
catastrophe and potential for tragedy or
you can tell another story of an
absolute failure of the human social
structure and the human individual level
because of the corruption to address a
problem that everyone knew was there and
so that's a good example of how things,
how the flood comes when you're not
behaving properly.
You know,
in.
One of the things that's quite
interesting about the old testament and
the people who wrote it is that they
always assume that if the flood comes,
that meant you weren't prepared.
If that's the rule,
right?
That it's like the a priori axiom.
I think he got flooded out,
hey,
you weren't prepared enough.
How can you tell what you got flooded
out,
right?
That's the evidence,
and you might say,
well,
that's not very fair.
It's fair isn't the point.
The point is do you want to get flooded
out again or not?
Because fair would be,
well,
you better figure out why you got
flooded out and fix it so it doesn't
happen again,
and that's the moral thing to do when
when you're thinking about morality as
walking the path,
it's most appropriate to get to the
destination that you think would be the
best possible destination
by the mere fact that it exists.
That is it lives in producers.
The cosmos gradually deteriorates.
It ends by falling into decay.
That is the reason why it has to be
recreated.
In other words,
the flood realizes on the macrocosmic
scale,
what is symbolically affected during the
new year festival,
the end of the world,
and the end of a sinful humanity in
order to make a new creation possible.
Well,
that's an interesting.
There's a lot of information packed into
those few lines.
Delete,
edit,
wrote,
because he also,
at the at at in the Mesopotamian
rituals,
the Mesopotamians would act out
the collapse of the kingdom into chaos
essentially after new year's festival.
It's kind of what you do when you make
resolutions because like it's a
degenerate,
what you'd say is our proclivity to make
new year's resolutions,
sort of a degenerate ritual,
and I don't mean that it's bad.
I mean that it,
it,
it's the remnants of something much
grander.
So the idea was,
well,
the Mesopotamians would take their
emperor outside the city,
the walled city and once a year and they
would make them kneel and they take off
all his king close and then they'd whack
them with a glove,
if I remember correctly,
the priest would do that and then they'd
make them recount all the ways that he
wasn't being a good emperor that year.
He wasn't being a good Marduk because
that was who he was supposed to be on
earth.
And that's the guy with eyes all the way
around his head speaks magic words that
transforms chaos into order.
That's what dampers supposed to do.
And so the question would be,
okay,
your emperor,
it's like,
have a little humility here because
you're not God incarnate.
He probably made some mistakes.
Can you think of any ways in the last
year that you didn't take every
advantage of every opportunity you
possibly could have to take some spare
chaos and transform it into a habit of
habitable order?
That's a good thing to think about.
Well,
that's what you're thinking about when
you make a new year's resolution,
even though you don't know it.
It's like,
well,
could you be a better person in the
upcoming year as well?
You can imagine the flood
and then you can set yourself straight
and then you can prepare for it.
And that means maybe you can stave it
off,
but it also means that maybe even if you
don't stave it off,
you could ride it out.
And that's actually the story of Noah
because what happens with Noah is that
he can see that things are not good and
that there's a flood coming and God is
maybe letting him know.
And it says in the story that Noah
walked with God,
remembering that's what Adam did before
he got all self conscious about the
whole thing.
He walked with God.
We'll talk about that more next time,
but what that would mean maybe is
because Noah was straight and he put
himself together and his familial
relationships were good because it also
says that that his antenna were working
and he could see little farther into
the future than someone whose vision was
completely obscured by,
by fog and chaos.
And he could tell that things were not
going to go well.
And so he prepared for it and because he
prepared for it well then things that
actually went pretty well for Noah,
even though the flood came.
And so that's an interesting thing
because that's an.
That's an indeterminant issue in human
existence.
How big a hurricane would it take to
wipe out New Orleans if everyone was
prepared?
Well,
the,
you're not going to wipe out the Dutch.
I mean that's going to be a tough one,
man.
You're going to have to conjure up a
pretty damn big storm to take out their
dykes.
Well,
how thoroughly defendant could New
Orleans be if nobody in the municipal
municipal and state governments was
corrupt?
Well,
end of the hurricane problem because
that's something that we could clearly
deal with.
We know how to do it and the same
applies in your own life is that there
are floods come and you can bloody well
be sure of that.
That's absolutely 100 percent certain.
Some of them are going to be personal,
some of them are going to be familial,
some of them are going to be social and
political and economic.
It's like,
are they going to be catastrophes for
you?
Or going to ride them out.
Are you going to prepare?
Well,
the first issue might be,
well,
do you have your act together well
enough to see them coming with enough
advanced warning so that you can take
proper measures.
Maybe just decide step it,
maybe just don't go where the flood is
going to be.
That's a simple thing,
but maybe you don't have that luxury.
Right?
And so it is going to be a catastrophe.
Maybe someone in your family is gonna
get really,
really sick.
Right?
And maybe maybe there's just a tiny
pathway through that,
that everything doesn't fall apart.
It doesn't end in divorce,
it doesn't end in death,
it doesn't end in sorrow,
doesn't end in catastrophe,
but the margin of error is slim down to
virtually zero in every imperfection
that you bring to that situation is
going to increase the probability that
that tragedy is going to turn it into
something indistinguishable from hell.
And that's coming.
It's coming your way.
Absolutely certainly.
And so then you might think,
well,
since it's coming your way,
maybe the best thing to do is to put
yourself together so that when it comes,
it can be the least amount of awful
possible.
So I'll close with this story.
This was a very affecting story for me.
My mother in law had frontal temporal
dementia and she developed it quite
young.
She was about 55,
something like that.
And her husband,
who is very extroverted,
man about town guy,
I grew up in a small town,
everybody knew him.
He was charismatic,
drank too much charismatic,
good businessmen.
Quite a remarkable person,
a real character,
but not exactly a family man.
Even though he,
he,
he provided for his family very,
but when
his wife got sick,
he really took care of her man.
He was something to see because that's
no joke.
Dealing with someone who has Alzheimer's
for all intents and purposes because
they get taken away from you piece by
piece and that is not pretty.
And then it's also hard,
right?
Not only is it catastrophic,
but it's hard and Jesus,
he just stepped into that like perfectly
and it was way less awful than it could
have been way.
It was just a tragedy.
It wasn't hell.
And then I was there when she died and
my wife's family are actually pretty
good at dealing with death.
As it turns out,
my wife's sister is a palliative care
nurse and you have to be a pretty tough
cookie to be a palliative care nurse,
but you can do it,
which is pretty interesting because that
means that you can go make relationships
with people at the last stages of their
life that are genuine relationships and
people just die on you nonstop.
And yet,
you know,
she's a competent,
alive,
alert,
fun person.
So like two thumbs up for her man,
that's someone you can rely on and in
tragedy and her other sister is a
pharmacist and my wife has volunteered
in palliative care wards and is also
very good at taking care of people who
are genuinely not in good health.
And so we were there when my mother in
law died.
And of course you can imagine here's a,
here's a deathbed situation for you.
Your mother in law is dying and
everyone's at each other's throats.
So like you think that's uncommon.
Then your eyes aren't open because it's
plenty bloody comment and then it's not
just a tragedy,
it's hell.
And like maybe you can stand the tragedy
but you can't stand the hell.
And in this situation that isn't what
happened is everybody pulled together
and what happened was while she died,
but what was so interesting was the
family,
he actually came together more tightly
as a consequences.
So although there is something taken
away,
on the one hand there was something
gained on the other that wasn't trivial.
And I'm not trying to be optimistic and
you know,
isn't the universe a wonderful place
about all this,
like someone died and in an ugly way and
it and it,
and it was harsh,
but God,
it was a hell of a lot better than it
could have been.
And maybe it was good enough.
That's the thing,
you know as that,
this is something that I constantly
wonder,
is that if people did what they could to
speak the truth and pay attention,
then maybe the tragedy that's part of
life wouldn't have to deteriorate into
the unbearable hell that doesn't have to
be part of life.
And maybe we could actually tolerate the
tragedy or maybe we could even rise
above it and maybe we could even
mitigate it,
you know,
because we can,
we do that sort of thing all the time.
And so it's always an open question
in the Iliad and put it very well.
Are the floods the consequence of the
fact that things fall apart?
Or are the floods that consequence of
the fact that people make mistakes that
they know they shouldn't make and make
anyways they sin?
Right?
And that's to miss the mark,
right?
Because that's an archery term to sit
in.
That means maybe they don't even specify
the damn target,
which is really,
you're not going to hit it unless you
specified or having specified.
They just say,
Oh,
to hell with it.
It's not that important.
It's like you gotta be careful when you
say something like to hell with it.
It's not that important because one of
the things that might happen to you if
you say to hell with it,
it's not that important,
is that you might actually end up in
hell for a pretty prolonged period of
time or maybe for the remainder of your
miserable existence.
Because it's certainly the case that
people do exist there and I've seen them
exists there and once you're there,
it's no trick.
It's no simple matter to get the hell
out.
And so it might matter that the things
that matter get addressed.
It might matter that you do what you can
to walk with God.
Like I said,
we'll talk more about that next time and
it might be that that is how you build
an Ark and are protected from the flood
even if the damn thing comes.
And the thing is,
it will,
and this is a funny thing too,
that I've noticed about our education
system and the way we teach students and
their trigger warnings and all of that
absolute rubbish.
I think in most of my lectures I'd have
to have a trigger warning every 15
seconds.
So I was like,
tell my students when they're young,
it's like,
look,
don't fool yourself.
You know you're going to develop a
serious illness.
At least one,
maybe two or three and one of them is
likely to be chronic and if it isn't
you,
it's going to be someone you love.
It's going to be your husband,
it's going to be your parent,
it's going to be your kids that's coming
and so as a lot of death and pain and so
like just exactly what sort of person
are you going to be when that shows up
and that's the right question.
It isn't how are you going to be happy
in your life?
It's like,
good luck with that.
It's a stupid ambition anyways,
as far as I'm concerned because it's too
shallow,
you know happiness.
You're lucky that comes,
comes and goes like the sun coming out
from behind the cloud.
If you're happy,
man,
more power to you.
Enjoy it,
enjoy it.
It's a.
it's a gift from the cosmos to be happy,
but at pursuit.
No,
no.
The pursuit is when the dam flood comes,
you want to be the person who built arc
and that's what the story of Noah is
about and the thing is the flood is
always coming.
That's another thing that's worth
commenting on with regards to this story
is you know,
there's an apocalyptic element to the
Judeo Christian tradition.
There's an idea that the end of the
world is always at hand and that you
should prepare to be judged.
And the thing about that is it's true
and the reason that's true is because
the end of your world is at hand and it
will certainly come and when it comes
you will be judged because it will be up
to you to figure out what to do with the
fact that your world just collapsed.
And that'll be a moral problem of
ultimate severity because it'll push you
right to your limits and you'll find out
exactly where your unaddressed
weaknesses lie because that's what
happens in a crisis.
And so the reason that that's an
archetypal reality and it looks
underneath the entire Judaeo Christian
structure,
the apocalypse,
the impending apocalypse,
is because we always live in apocalyptic
times and your world is always in small
ways and large ways coming to an end.
And so what do you do?
You prepare for it,
you prepare for your world to come to an
end and then maybe when the end comes,
you get another world.
That'd be a good deal.
So we're ready for this next week.
Thank you.
My question was regarding the online
university you plan to create and the
plans you have for that.
My uh,
we've spoke briefly last week and I want
to ask you,
how can a student such as myself get
involved with this process?
Yeah.
Well,
an online university that's perhaps a
grandiose ambition,
right?
But one of the things that,
so here's my,
here's my rationale.
You know,
lots of things have dramatically
transformed in the last 20 years and
whole swaths of
enterprise has been wiped out and that's
happening in a more and more rapid rate
as our technology progresses right now,
newspapers are in the process of dying.
I actually think they're in the process
of committing suicide,
but they're in the process of dying and
that's going to happen very rapidly.
I think the globe and Mail lost 10
percent of its readership in the last
three months,
something like that.
And so what happens is that new
technologies come along to supplant the
old technologies.
And I've watched a number of businesses
fail,
some large businesses.
I knew some people who worked at digital
equipment corporation when it was
failing and I've had some inside track
into failing businesses and I see when
they start to fail,
they tend to failure process tends to
tip and then accelerate.
It can happen unbelievably quickly and
this is what it looks to me.
This is how it looks to me in
relationship to the universities,
especially in the US,
although not only,
especially in humanities,
although not only
so number
one,
so I've recorded three years of my
personality lecture say,
so let's have three years of lectures on
Freud now.
What I should do with those,
I think his Eq,
edit them into one really good lecture
on Freud and then stop giving that
lecture because why would I give that
lecture again because I've already given
it an edited.
It's in good shape,
and if it's a really good lecture,
then why does someone else have to give
the lecture?
Why does 300 other people have to give a
lecture on Freud and you know what I
mean?
What's going to happen is there's gonna
be some really good lectures on subjects
and that's all that people are going to
need or want because the Internet tends
to move things towards winner take all
very,
very rapidly and so it seems to me that
we're already at a point technologically
where we could identify 100 things that
people really need to know and do a
sequence of lectures on those things
that were outstanding and then they can
be updated and attitude,
but then it's like it's a done game and
it's free.
So I know it started thinking about this
last year when I noticed that my
psychology lectures had a million views
and that was last April and I thought,
that's amazing.
A million views.
It's like,
what the hell that's,
I don't know what to make of that.
That's not the best set.
That's the kind of best selling book
that you never right,
because no one ever writes a bestselling
book,
so a million views.
That's something to pay attention to and
now it's way more than that,
but there's videos and podcasts and that
means that people can listen when
they're doing other things too and so
that's really cool and maybe people can
listen better than they can read.
That's a real possibility because we've
only been reneged silently for about,
well,
most of like most of humanity for less
than a hundred years and virtually no
one could read silently 500 years ago,
so really new skill and so maybe we're
better at listening and so all of a
sudden there's the possibility of
disseminating high quality educational
material,
highly produced,
highly vetted to millions of people for
nothing.
Well,
how are you going to compete with that?
Then?
Then it's worse because the humanities
which have become completely
degenerated,
almost completed,
degenerate,
in my estimation,
have abandoned their valuable
intellectual property,
which is the collective wisdom,
at least for the west of of Western
civilization just sitting there.
Someone might as well steal it back and
then there's the student loan debt cycle
in the United States,
if that's pronounced properly,
tobacco,
okay.
Obviously I've read that word more than
set it and so you know,
and so,
you know,
I had a guy write me today and he asked
if he should go to a private college for
$22,000
a year to produce produce to pursue an
undergraduate in psychology so that he
could he get into clinical graduate
school or go to another university,
the State University for far less.
I told him to go the state university
because it's the wise economic decision,
but you know,
it doesn't seem to me that it's
reasonable at all to load people up when
they're 22 with $100,000
of student debt that they cannot declare
bankruptcy for its indentured servitude
and there and to load up people when
they're 22 or 23 with debt of that
magnitude.
It's like,
well how the hell are they going to be
entrepreneurs?
How are you going to take a risk with
$100,000
debt load and who's going to marry you?
Well really Jesus,
you know,
because another story I heard recently
was,
well I just got married to my partner.
She brought into the marriage $120,000
in student debt.
It's like,
oh my God.
It's like it's crippling man.
Like once you're.
Once you're making a substantial amount
of money,
if you're fortunate,
maybe you're in your forties,
you could handle a debt load like that,
but in your twenties it's just
crippling.
So you know the tuition fees of rat have
ratcheted up like mad in the last 30
years.
The unit,
the colleges and universities have
become unbelievably administratively,
top heavy.
They're regulated to death by the,
by the legislative system.
So there's ethics committees which are
so counterproductive that it's just
unbelievable.
There's this entire whole whole new
monstrous hyper accommodation movement
that that's that borders on.
Well,
I'll make a video about that soon
enough.
That's absolutely pathological and
there's this whole postmodern,
neo Marxist idea.
See that's going on in the universities
and so like,
well,
how many mistakes does an institute plus
students aren't being taught how to
speak.
They're not being taught how to debate.
They're not being taught how to write
and they don't read difficult things.
They read French intellectual
postmodernists,
right,
and they probably don't read those
either.
They read secondarily derive.
They Skim secondarily derived papers
about French intellectual postmarks.
This postmodern is from the 19 seventies
and the standards have been lowered
because there's too many people pursuing
higher education and so I think,
okay,
there's eight dimensions of success and
on every single dimension there's
failure.
The system's done the end.
So the vision would be why not provide
everybody in the world with high quality
education in the humanities for like one
50th.
The cost you can charge for
accreditation.
That's a whole separate issue,
right?
Accreditation,
but the but the resources,
it's like why not make them available to
everyone?
So that's the plan.
I mean I don't know if I can do it or
not,
but it's partly what I'm doing with his
biblical lecture series.
It's sort of putting my toe in the
water,
but I have a plan and I have some good
programmers who are willing to help and
there's lots of people out there that
would help.
God.
I'm being flooded with offers of help.
I'd love to take people up on the
offers,
but it's not that easy to get someone to
help you do something,
you know,
so that'd be the plan.
It's like,
so what would the plan be?
Give people a high quality education in
the classic humanities,
teach them how to speak and write a
credit them for one 10th the current
cost and do it with millions of people
instead of tens of thousands of asking
what plans do you have for the
accreditation side where people can show
something for what the time they spend
watching?
Well,
one of the things that I would do for
example,
is imagine that you were in a course and
so you have taken exam.
Let's say it's a multiple choice exam
just for the sake of argument because
they're simpler.
The writing issue is a separate problem.
Well,
so one of the things that you would do
if you enrolled in the courses generate
multiple choice questions.
That'd be one of your assignments.
Here's a lecture,
generate 10 multiple choice questions.
Now you've got a thousand people
generating 10 multiple choice questions.
Well then you can do.
There are statistical procedures that
help you figure out what valid multiple
choice questions are.
You could have people vote on them for
that matter if we put them on a website,
assignment number two,
here's 100 multiple choice questions.
Pick the 10 that you think are most
representative of the knowledge that
you've acquired.
Get 100 people to do that so you get
crowdsource the test construction and
then you could keep making the test
better and better as well because you
could build that.
I'd like to build the system so that it
was self improving with a minimum of
administrative interference and so then
what would happen is that as you got
accredited,
so you start reading exams and maybe
write more and more of them.
Then you'd start to by voting power with
regards to the content of the courses
and maybe even the right to produce
courses to put them up online.
So something like that.
But our,
our strategy would be to build.
We want to build a system that's
basically autonomous and self improving
right from the beginning.
So minimum of administrative overhead,
extremely low cost,
widespread availability,
crowdsourced and its structure and an
autonomous self improving.
I think we can do that.
I don't know if I can do it,
but I think we have the technology to do
that.
And then you think,
well,
so here's the plan,
you know,
because you're,
I'm always thinking of the point,
point b,
what's a good thing to do with life?
While the good,
good thing to do with your life is the
most difficult God damned thing you can
think of that would do the most possible
good.
That'll get you up in the morning.
And so because you think,
why should I get up in the morning?
So like,
well,
you know,
I've got $50 million people to educate.
Hey,
that'll do it.
Really,
you know that,
that battle that'll overcome a lot of
anx,
that sort of thinking so well.
So it seems to me that,
it seems to me that it's inevitable now
whether or not I can do it,
that's a whole different story,
but I can certainly start it and I'm
going to start it.
My partner,
my business partner,
the guy who helped me develop the self
authoring program,
which thousands of people are using that
now and we've helped thousands,
tens of thousands of students now stay
in university.
So that's really cool.
Well maybe not given the state of the.
I'm contributing to the problem,
but you know,
but they're,
but they're sticking out their plans.
That's the point.
They're actually making plans and
sticking them out.
So.
So I think that we can and we know how
to start small with the way to build a
big system is to build a small system
that works and then scale it.
And so that's.
I've been talking with my partner,
his name is Daniel Higgins.
Uh,
I have another partner,
Bob Peele who used to be my graduate
supervisor at mcgill and we'd been
working on this sort of thing for about
25 years and our goal has been right
from the beginning to build low cost,
high quality psychoeducational
interventions and bring them to his wife
Deb market as possible.
So,
and my Daniel in particular is devoted
most of his life to doing that.
It's been about 20 years now,
so,
so while that's a sketch of it all,
outline more of it on,
on the web at some point,
but that's kind of what,
what we've been deciding what we've been
planning to do.
Alright.
Thank you very much.
Yep.
Thank you.
When you were on the Rubin report not
too long ago,
uh,
in that discussion you mentioned how a
use of psilocybin straightened out and,
uh,
can produce these transcendent
experiences which is jarring for a
person who may have traditionally,
which for someone who became a Christian
as a result of their only time doing
magic mushrooms as jarring piece of
information,
I was just wondering if you could expand
on what you find intriguing about
religious experience and what we can
know about the transcendent from them.
If anything,
that's a tough one,
man.
The relationship between entheogenic
use,
let's say,
which is sometimes what those chemicals
are described and religious experiences
unspecified,
but it looks like it's profound.
There was a man named Gordon West Saul
who wrote a book for,
I remember correctly called Soma.
He was investigating the potential use
of emoney to miscarrying mushrooms among
the people who wrote the Hindu holy
scriptures thousands of years ago,
and he felt that he identified the
chemical that they were using the sacred
drink.
Um,
the use of Iowasca and psilocybin
mushrooms and so forth as well document,
particularly in North America and the
evidence,
the empirical evidence that under
certain conditions those chemicals can
produce religious experiences is
absolutely overwhelming.
There's been good research done recently
at Johns Hopkins looking at Psilocybin,
the first research that's been done on
hallucinogens really in 30 years because
people were so terrified of them in the
sixties and for good reason.
I'm indicated that the people that they
dosed with Psilocybin,
about 75 percent of them had a mystical
experience which they regarded as one of
the five,
three to five most important experiences
of their life.
And a year later we're characterized by
permanent personality transformation,
which was an increase in trade openness
of one standard deviation,
which is a lot by the way.
It moves you from 50th percentile,
the 85th percentile,
for example.
It's a,
it's a huge move.
And that look permanent now whether or
not that's a good thing,
that's a whole different issue,
but they're very,
very powerful.
And they also did some recent research
showing that psilocybin mushrooms were
an unbelievably effective smoking
cessation intervention.
So if I remember correctly,
and I may have this wrong because it's
been a while since I read it,
they had an 80 percent success rate in,
in stopping people from using a tobacco
with one silicide been experience and so
well.
So those things are very,
all of that's very interesting to me and
I don't exactly know what to make of it.
I don't know what to make of it at all.
Not even a little bit,
but um,
but the evidence for the relationship
between met mystical experiences and
hallucinogen use of certain types is
incontrovertible.
And I don't.
And I don't think anybody else knows
what to derive from that.
I mean,
one conclusion is something like
religious experiences are a common
concomitant of going temporarily insane
and that it's not a bad hypothesis
because you see,
for example,
in the prodrome of illnesses like
schizophrenia and sometimes manic
depressive disorder two on the
mannequin,
you do see the emergence often of
religious type delusions.
It's not that common,
but it's not uncommon,
so it's definitely the case that if your
brain function has been detrimentally
affected,
one of the consequences can be
experiences that are subjectively
experienced as indistinguishable from
the religious.
You also see the same thing in cases of
epilepsy,
especially in the pro Jeroma,
so if you have an epileptic condition,
sometimes you know that you're going to
have a seizure.
You can feel it mounting and often,
or at least occasionally,
those experiences are associated with an
elevation of religious sensation
deepening meaning that increases in its
depth and complexity until it's
overwhelming and that's what
subjectively brings on the seizure.
Now,
God only knows how to disentangle
causality in a circumstance like that.
Dostoevsky had seizures like that,
by the way,
so,
so the,
the,
the pessimistic viewpoint is
religious phenomenology.
As a consequence of brain disorder,
the positive more positive side is no
religious experience is a category of
experienced that's within the realm of
human possibility and there are
different modes of eliciting it and we
know that there are many modes of
eliciting it.
Fasting can elicit it dancing under some
circumstances.
Music enlisted at music elicits that
regularly.
I mean basically as far as I'm
concerned,
rock concerts are indistinguishable from
religious rituals.
The rituals,
not like they don't come with a dogmatic
overlay,
let's say,
but the ritualistic structure is there
and maybe it's there just listening to
music.
Um,
what that means for the investigation of
hallucinogens.
I have no idea.
And I would also certainly use the
caution that Carl,
you've developed when he was talking
about hallucinogens and he did that I
think only a very brief number of times.
And I think in relationship to Elvis
Huxley's original work on Mescalin
experiences,
he said,
beware of wisdom that you didn't earn.
And that's very,
very smart.
So I would say there is something to be
learned about.
There's something,
there's a lot to be learned about
hallucinogens.
There may be something to be learned
from them,
but having said that,
if you play with fire,
you end up burnt generally speaking.
So I'm all do.
Caution is in effect.
So one more,
I know your analysis,
Huxley Fan.
So I thought I'd ask you this question,
um,
after reading his book,
doors of perception in which he gives an
account of his experience taking the
psychedelic drug Mescalin he stated that
in the final stages of egolessness,
there is an obscene knowledge.
Is that all,
is in all that
actually each.
He then went on to say that this is as
near I take it as a finite mind can ever
get to perceiving everything that is
happening in the universe.
Uh,
I was wondering if maybe you could
explain what that means because I've
been trying to understand it.
Yeah.
There is a neuroscientist a while back,
whose name I don't remember who had a
stroke and she being a neuroscientist,
was analyzing the neurological
consequences of the stroke as it
occurred,
if I remember correctly,
the stroke either temporarily or
permanently took out the function of
large portions of her left hemisphere.
And she had exactly that experience.
It was an experience of ego dissolution,
something like that.
The,
the,
the felt sense of,
of identity shifting from that sort of
narrow boundary maybe that you would
define by the boundary of your physical
being into something that was much
broader and much like it gets,
it gets.
It gets hard to describe this without,
you know,
degenerating into hippie poetry from
1967 very,
very rapidly.
But it's something like a,
a sense,
a sense of,
of the underlying unity of consciousness
that might be one way of thinking about
we don't know much about consciousness.
In fact,
I don't think we know anything about
consciousness and obviously
consciousness is something that we all
share,
but it's also something that we seem to
also experience individually,
but maybe our individual consciousness.
Is there something like the
manifestations of something that's a
more unified consciousness underneath.
I mean that's hardly an original idea,
but it does seem to be the case that
under some circumstances there are
neurological transformations that make
that
link more apparent.
Assuming that the link exists now,
you could say,
well no,
they're just producing a delusion,
but the funny thing about,
you know,
the funny thing about delusions is that
you've got to think,
well,
how do you know something's a delusion
and the answer that has to be something
like,
well,
hardly anyone else thinks that that
would be criteria number one.
Criteria number two would be if you act
on the delusion,
do does your ships sink because if
you're sick ship sinks,
then it was a delusion.
It's something like that.
But if you act on your delusion and
things get better,
well then maybe it wasn't a delusion and
there's no evidence from the silicide
been studies that have been conducted at
Johns Hopkins that there was detrimental
effects for the participants and the
participants certainly don't think that
the effects were detrimental.
So,
and I've been hesitant to talk about any
of this for obvious reasons.
I'll tell you something really funny.
I think it's funny.
Anyways,
I had timothy leary's old job at
Harvard,
so you know,
and so larry is a good object lesson and
being very careful about this sort of
thing because it certainly,
it isn't obvious that his net effect was
good
and I say that with some caution because
Larry was a very smart person and he was
very creative,
but he got tangled up in that
hallucinogenic madhouse,
you know,
that had characterized the say the
period from 1965 to about 1970 and it,
it,
it didn't seem to me that that was
altogether a good thing.
Thing is we have these chemicals now in
our culture and people are experimenting
with them like mad and making them
illegal doesn't seem to be working in
large part because there,
I think there were seven known seven to
20 known psychoactive substances that
were illegal in the year 2000 and
something like 400 now because labs all
over the world keep tweaking the
molecules,
right?
Because molecule is illegal,
so chemists just shifted a little bit.
Then they have a new hallucinogen and
which might be fine.
It might not be because now and then you
can produce a chemical that's
unbelievably dangerous.
Fentanyl's sort of like that.
There was a drug a while back that I can
name,
I can't remember the name.
It was an acronym.
It was a fun drug.
If you took it once,
it gave you a permanent,
irreversible,
total Parkinson's disease so people
would take it and they were frozen and
that was it.
So MPTP I think it was called so it
because it destroyed the same area of
the brain that the Parkinson's destroys,
except it did it right away.
So,
uh,
you know,
designer drugs,
right?
A little caution is in order,
how we might approach the issue of
hallucinogen use in a mature manner.
Well,
that's a topic for an entirely other
discussion.
I'm not even necessarily sure that it
can be approached that way,
although I would say at minimum,
determining what it is that you're up to
if you're going to experiment,
would be a good thing.
Like what is it exactly that you're
serving?
They're not party drugs,
they're not for fun,
right?
Whatever they are,
that's not what they're for.
And so maybe they could be used by
people who are carefully orienting
themselves towards the good.
Although I wouldn't say that that should
be read as a recommendation.
Thank you.